This is Jocko podcast number one 34 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo and good evening.
Okay.
Maybe
I was always in the wrong place at the wrong time.
I can see where someone could get that idea,
but I actually don't think that,
I don't think that at all.
It's in fact quite the opposite.
Now
looking back,
of course there were some,
some tough times.
There were some awful times
I'd even go so far as to say there were some wretched times.
There were nights filled with discomfort and stress and fear and there was
pressure
and sometimes that pressure was
so great that I thought my mind just might fracture
and break apart.
Yeah.
But fortunately I could tell you that I didn't break.
There were times,
there were times when I saw the cracks.
Okay.
I saw the cracks starting to split open and I had to work hard to keep it
together,
but that's the way it was in my old line of work.
My old line of work had some definite downsides
cause it on top of all that pressure and stress and fear and discomfort.
Okay.
There was death
even during peacetime,
even during peace time,
I lost friends and I lost teammates.
Okay.
It goes with the personality profile.
They would say risk takers.
So even piece provided little piece.
And then once the war started,
it just escalated.
Not just for me,
not by any stretch whatsoever.
Every military member has dealt with death in some way over the past 17 years of
war,
some more than others.
They've also been life changing wounds
of which I was spared.
I was lucky,
but many others,
we're not so lucky
because the bombs and the bullets and the Iud is,
and the mortars and the rockets,
they do not care who you are at all.
But
for whatever reason,
I made it through,
I was lucky
and now
my life goes on.
They may be,
I'm a little more paranoid than the next person and maybe I don't always sleep
that well.
And maybe there's times when some fought or some memory catches me off guard and
I end up reliving a moment from the past,
a moment from the past that I wish I could change.
Yeah.
And you might think,
wouldn't I just want to change it all?
Yeah.
When I want to go back and erase all that pain and replace it with relief,
then replace it with ease and with comfort
and the answer to that question is no
practice.
Not just no,
it's hell no.
Okay.
Because wrapped up in that pain and wrapped up in that discomfort and wrapped up
in that stress and anxiety wrapped up in all that is the polar opposites of all
those feelings.
Inside all that turmoil,
there was relief.
There was certainty,
there was happiness,
there was a focus and security and there was peace,
peace
of mind in knowing that
no matter what,
no matter what horrors be fell me,
things would be okay
and that is because I knew that my brothers would take care of me no matter
what.
Okay?
You see my old job allowed me to work with some of the best guys in the world.
Not all of them.
You've heard me talk about that before.
There's substandard people in every organization in the world.
There's a bell curve
in the bottom of the bell curve is filled with the same
deficient people you'll find anywhere.
Okay.
Lazy scamming,
irresponsible,
self centered,
whatever.
But at the high end of that bell curve,
the guys I worked with were righteous and no bull and hardworking and it was
humbling to be around them.
Now,
where are they?
Perfect.
No,
none of us are.
Did they have flaws?
Yes,
absolutely.
All of us fall short,
but could I count on them?
Could I count on them without question and without hesitation
100%
through all the horror and the fear and the pressure,
there were always some guys that I knew without a shred of doubt,
which stand beside me and hold the line no matter what.
Okay.
They would never let me down
ever.
And
as fate would have it,
I'm lucky enough to have one of those few men that I knew I could always count
on no matter what.
Here with me tonight.
Okay.
He's done more for me and for the teams and for our great nation and the world
is ever going to know.
His name is Mike Cirelli.
He's a former recon marine,
but very recently retired seal officer
and he's someone that's let me down.
So Mike,
welcome to the podcast and thanks for coming on brother.
Hey Jocko.
Happy to be here in Echo.
Thank you for having me.
So you retired how long ago?
March 1st March 1st and so no one knows anything about you,
which is the way it is.
And um,
so let's get to know a little bit about you starting with the beginning.
Let's start nor cow or a cow.
That's where you were born.
Right in nor cal Palo Alto,
California.
Just about 30 minutes south of San Francisco.
Entire family born and raised in San Francisco.
They're all still back there except for my brother or white fish,
Montana.
But uh,
you know what?
Nothing,
nothing to really lack in terms of growing up at,
I had a great family.
Um,
you know,
sometimes I describe growing up in this house,
the Sorelli household is a being in 1960s,
1950s,
Germany.
Berlin,
except I was on the,
yeah,
the wrong side of the wall.
No,
I grew up in a very Catholic family,
loving parents,
very,
uh,
very strict,
stern parents.
But I got the,
uh,
the benefit of being the last child.
And by that,
you know,
that point they older brother and sister,
they'd worn down.
They down your parents a little bit,
you,
they'd worn down my parents a little bit.
And so I got away with bloody murder to a point.
Um,
but you know,
standard,
uh,
you know,
upbringing of a seal.
Uh,
I had my share of,
uh,
of trouble,
that a cost and a,
that's probably why I went the path that I went.
At what point did you,
at what point did you realize that you are going to go in the military?
So,
you know,
I can't pinpoint a specific moment,
but everything was driving that,
driving me that way.
I did have a grandfather that was a first of the five oh first.
Oh Wow.
In World War II.
I actually,
he trained with a patent out in,
um,
oh,
it,
uh,
it uh,
yeah,
the are trading center.
Yes.
I assume they actually trained at the eye.
The lake.
Oh,
okay.
Near,
uh,
near Niland.
Oh,
okay.
Salton Sea.
And so read,
actually hit the very early part of Africa and then came back to the states,
uh,
when airborne and he was a quartermaster for the first of the five Oh six fifth,
I'm sorry,
first of the five o first.
And then the last,
he still went through airborne training.
He would jump in with them.
And so he was actually a third day of Normandy drop day and then,
uh,
fought in the battle of the bulge in the black forest.
It's so that humble confidence that he never spoke about.
And so my mom would naturally tell me stories and,
um,
it wasn't until I became a marine that he actually,
you know,
really
revealed a lot of the stories from,
uh,
from World War Two.
And then,
you know,
as he got older and it was,
it was the same stories,
but I would sit there and listen for the 15th time as if it was the first time I
was,
you know,
airing it out of respect.
You know,
it's interesting.
I was talking to Dave Burke once again today.
Good deal.
Dave,
we were talking about reading about face and uh,
I was saying,
hey,
you know,
when you were reading about w w the older I got,
the more it meant to me.
And there's a quote from Musashi that I talked about in the podcast,
which is,
it's something like this and I'm not going to get it perfectly right,
but it's something like this when you know the way,
then you see the way in all things.
So about faces,
not a leadership book at all.
But when you read it and you are thinking about leadership,
it's just all about leadership.
It's 100% about leadership.
But it reminds me of what you're saying,
like when you're little,
when you're a kid and you don't know the way yet,
and your grandfather could be telling you these stories and it sounds kind of
cool or whatever,
but compared to when you actually know and understand Warren and you,
it's just a totally different story.
And as a matter of fact,
speaking to that,
when you were running the Johnson course,
I was,
I came in and I was going to do like the brief that I would do to the Johnson
course and you know,
you were there.
It was like the 10th time you were going to watch it.
And I was like,
Hey,
are you going to hang out and watch this?
Are you just going to leave and go do like work out or something?
And you're like,
no,
I'm,
I'm gonna stick around.
And I was like,
well,
why are you for what?
And you're like,
I learned something new every time.
I was like,
Dang.
So that's pretty,
uh,
definitely when you get older you can appreciate some of these things from,
um,
when you know the way,
let's look at extreme ownership.
I mean,
this is why you hear people that are like,
Hey,
I'm reading it for the seventh time.
Yeah.
Because they will get 10 new things or their perspective has changed.
That's the Bin and learn.
That's the part that I didn't account for.
And I don't know who told me this is,
somebody told me this,
like it was someone that had come to multiple masters and I said,
well you know,
how'd you like this one?
And all the monsters are a little bit different.
But the first three were not that different.
The first three were the same,
almost the same.
And someone said,
well it's only been a year,
but my perspective is totally different now cause I've been promoted one time
and I've got different situations going on.
So it's,
I'm seeing it differently.
So that's,
that's another thing that happens as you get older.
So back to you,
how did you pick the Marine Corps?
Or did the Marine Corps Cook you
a little bit of both?
Uh,
out of options?
No.
Hey,
so your standard again,
high school sports,
um,
loved running,
loved wrestling,
uh,
the grades not so much.
It wasn't for a lack of aptitude.
There was a lack of complete effort.
And so,
you know,
loved to party if it didn't have to do with parties or girls.
Uh,
I wasn't involved.
Yeah.
And so I actually was the only one in my high school class and not to graduate.
Yes,
we got that going for you.
My mom is a,
is a little [inaudible] a woman and uh,
she,
you know,
she really is the rock of the family and you have to know how to play her.
My Dad is just the disciplinary and you feared him?
Uh,
yeah.
You just feared them.
Bottom line.
But you're,
you know,
my mom was a nurturer and the disciplinarian,
you just had to play both sides because once you put her on the,
onto the disciplinary side,
you just had no safe a safe house whatsoever,
anywhere in the Israeli household.
Um,
so they did,
you know,
my dad had served in Vietnam,
in the reserves.
He did not have to go to Vietnam because he had a very unique skill.
He was very good at football.
And back in the day he was stationed at Fort Polk,
Louisiana,
Louisiana.
He got assigned to the football team and that's what he did in the,
uh,
the army.
But very different army wasn't a fan of the military.
It just,
you know,
we were different in those regards,
but we're,
we're very much alike.
Um,
so I went off to the University of Colorado,
Colorado,
boulder,
the how did you do this median can graduate high school and you get,
you know,
so I went,
went back for the summer school,
summer session and finished the requirement.
Uh,
I'd already been accepted into the University of Colorado Boulder.
This,
the early stage of my life is not just parents can't say there's a whole lot of
pride there from the end of high school until about the first year in college.
So,
uh,
I did not pick up a ROTC and naval ROTC scholarship at Boulder,
but you can enroll as a,
uh,
a volunteer.
It helps to pick it up a scholarship.
So I joined the naval ROTC at University Colorado Boulder and,
uh,
shortly got kicked out,
um,
just for getting in trouble.
And I remember the,
the Battalion Mitch Shipping Commander pulled me in for my counseling and said,
you will never become a navy seal.
And also at that time,
you want to be in the seal teams.
You shoe.
I would,
I was going between the seals and force recon and you know,
Lo and behold,
we had this guy,
Ben,
I won't use his last name.
He was a force recon marine,
fifth force at the University of Colorado Boulder as a marine,
Misa marine enlisted commissioning education program,
uh,
a marine and was just impressive.
Built like a little tank.
Uh,
everything about him,
articulate,
smart,
confident,
not the loudest guy in the room.
Uh,
and so he sort of took me under his wings.
I hit,
don't worry about it.
Um,
college is not going to work out for you is go around.
Why don't you do what you want to do.
And uh,
you know,
walked me down to the,
uh,
the recruiting office in Boulder,
Colorado,
signed up.
And when I signed up,
I came back to northern California for a few months while I was waiting for my,
uh,
my bootcamp date,
enjoyed myself.
And then when it was time to go,
uh,
you know,
I sort of dropped the last minute and information on my parents.
Mom,
having a father that was in the military,
she accepted it pretty well.
And,
uh,
for my father,
he was a,
he was not happy given his,
you know,
everything is about our perceptions in life,
in his perception.
His experience with the army was not favorable one.
And so he was livid and um,
you know,
we had a few words and he did not see me off to the airport,
my brother and uh,
my mother did.
Um,
and then fast forward to a to boot camp.
Ben again had a,
had given me some good advice like,
hey,
you can turn this around in the marine corps will give you every,
every opportunity to do that until I crushed it in bootcamp,
graduated honor man out of like 300 kids and on graduation day or the day prior,
you know,
the parents can come out and see ya in the lineup,
the entire,
uh,
recruit battalion and Lo and behold,
who's in front carrying the guide on me.
And that's the one time,
you know what,
me and my father did not get along in high school.
Cause again,
not his fault,
you just see them doing this and shaking his head.
And you ever since that time,
my father and I see each other in a different light.
We still clash because we were so alike.
But,
uh,
we,
you know,
we've got a common understanding and uh,
he's just a good man.
My parents are good folks.
I couldn't,
you know,
I was never want for love for discipline.
Um,
in this really household.
It was a great house.
It's weird too because as a parent you're always thinking
if you try and impose too much on your kids,
you're just gonna,
you're just gonna push them in the other direction.
You know what I'm saying?
So,
you know,
like for instance,
your dad could have been like,
no,
you're not joining it and you would have been so rebellious,
probably would have joined anyways and done,
you know,
you then you would just not got along even more.
But he had to just be like,
okay,
I'm not going to see you off,
but I'll be there at graduation.
Dude,
I'll put to you this way.
I love the Marine Corps
best run service,
albeit they're the small service,
best run service in the u s military.
You just can't debate that.
Um,
and I think what he saw was he sent a boy off in like within three months he saw
the beginning of a man and I mean,
he loved it.
He took it on wholesale.
He loved it so much that he would pass by a recruiting office.
He'd stopped,
get some donuts
and bring them into the office and shake your hands.
I mean he,
he loved the military at this point.
He sought from a different,
I mean we literally changed his experience in Vietnam to a favorable one.
Yeah.
The Marine Corps has really just mastered that whole thing of taking a recruit
and turning them into a marine.
They,
they really good at that.
They are really good.
It's awesome.
The thing I said about the,
the Marine Corps has theirs,
you know,
in the seal teams,
you'll get the totally great guys at the high end of the spectrum and you'll get
real bad,
much worse.
Guys at the lower end,
the spectrum,
the Marine Corps,
it just keeps it all in.
It's much tighter group.
Like you know what you're getting.
It's going to be,
it's going to be a marine and he's going to be good to go.
You were talking about like their minute a bangle.
Yeah,
they're admitted.
It's a tight shot group.
The seal teams,
you know,
we get some,
we get some awesome guys for sure.
But then you get a couple scattered around this out there.
A couple of stray rounds that are off paper.
Don't,
don't worry about that little check.
So,
so then what,
what year was this now?
Cause this is like 1998 and 99 was,
it was 98,
98.
So,
so glad I came in before nine 11 cause I got to see the pre war military,
uh,
and then became what I call the,
the g watt babies that were absolutely spoiled in this.
Sounds contradictory is fueled by war.
Yeah.
So what would you do?
Would you,
what was your mls?
So went in as a uh,
Jesus,
I'm even forgetting it.
Uh,
oh,
three 11 rifleman.
Check.
But,
so when I was at the school of imagery,
these recon marines show up and you could always tell the recon marines,
they have the dual cool,
the,
the job,
you have to double trouble and the hair's a little longer and they stand a
little taller.
And uh,
so unbeknownst to me,
they,
they literally had to try out that,
uh,
that day.
And so that was my opportunity to get into recon early.
And,
uh,
I did extremely well,
finished first within that class and they're like,
okay,
did you want to go round?
I said,
yes,
absolutely.
And so out of the school of Infantry,
when I graduated from there,
it was straight to the base constant scores right next to buds.
Wow.
In Core Natto uh,
for three months.
And you guys get to go straight through that pipeline like that.
So you knew what it ebbed and flowed.
Usually you had to do some infantry time before you try it out.
But I think,
uh,
you know,
similar to,
to,
to the demands of a post nine 11 when we started out,
we were the green Brae community started opening up the 18 x program for guys
straight off the street into the special forces.
Recon would occasionally do the same thing.
And so very few.
And I just happened to hit a at an opportune time,
uh,
pass the screening and I'll tell you what,
BRC was tough and I have nothing but respect for those guys.
It's,
you know,
it's not,
they don't have a hell week,
but it is,
uh,
it is man town,
in every respect.
Yeah,
no,
I used to see those guys.
Obviously we'd see him all the time going through classes and then so,
and then you show up.
Where'd you go?
Where'd you go after that?
So first recon battalion at Camp Pendleton.
Sure.
It was,
it was quickly thrown into schools.
It was awesome.
So,
uh,
got dive school right off the bat,
which is the marine combatant dive course in Panama City,
Florida,
which was a,
I'll tell you what,
and uh,
most seals don't like to hear this.
It was as tough as second phase,
if not tougher.
And even academically,
uh,
they,
they dove in a lot deeper to the dive physics,
the guy of medicine.
So you had guys getting dropped for,
uh,
for academics.
Um,
and then after that it was shortly off to sniper school,
which I was ill prepared for.
Uh,
loved.
I remember my mom,
I went back to San Francisco,
uh,
cause I had a weekend off and you got to build your own Ghillie suits and I
built the worst Ghillie suit that you probably have ever seen.
I still have the thing in storage.
It looks like Chewbacca lying on the ground.
Um,
but past that school by the skin of my teeth and I think we started with 40,
and we graduated 12 and it literally came down to the last stock.
And,
uh,
a guy named Brian from Idaho who had been with a stale platoon in the marine
corps,
which is more or less a sniper platoon.
And uh,
literally helped me get into my last position and sacrificed himself cause he
didn't need to score a perfect score on that run.
And a in past,
but I made up for it and that,
you know,
the shooting who've,
yeah,
shoot,
the shooting was not a problem.
It was just stocking,
uh,
since I had no real preparatory work going in and those guys had it,
it was tough.
How was your patient's level during Stockton was a good,
it was a,
you know,
it,
it was decent.
Uh,
the problem was we,
we went to sniper school in January in California,
which is cold.
And so we were out there all the time,
sometimes rain.
And so it,
you know,
the patients was,
it was fine.
It was just the pain of sitting there,
um,
which,
which he had to contend with.
And then,
and then do you go on deployment?
No.
So did a,
a entire workup and actually shifted over to,
to another platoon because I was at first recon battalion and it was a company
at the time and we turned into a battalion when I was there.
So I transferred from seven platoon to a new platoon and continued to a workup
and,
uh,
had a great officer,
um,
pulled me aside and he's like,
Hey man,
uh,
I want to put you in for the reset program,
which again is the marine enlisted commissioning education program for the
listeners.
That's where they send an active duty marine,
usually a corporal sergeant or staff sergeant to go back and get their college
degree on the Marine Corps dime and then come back as an officer.
It's because you've shown some promise.
What I say is I'd only been to alcohol related incidents in the Marine Corps.
And so I said,
hey your,
your honor,
I'm joking.
But uh,
so the,
the officer put me in,
I filled out the package and got selected as a corporal very early in my career.
And so,
uh,
when they asked me what I wanted to go,
I wanted to go to the university.
University of Texas did not get in because what's the track back?
They look at high school.
And so,
uh,
believe it or not,
I'd been to a wedding in Austin,
one of my recon buddies and love the town.
And,
uh,
the same guy looked at me,
he's like,
hey man,
Wah Wah,
why don't you try a Texas a and m?
He's like,
it's like the next best thing.
It's only about an hour and a half outside of,
uh,
Austin.
I'm like,
okay,
all right.
And of course,
I'm a corporal at the time,
I don't have the money to go visit Texas a and m internet was not exactly
booming at that time.
And,
uh,
so I just submitted an application,
actually some marines that were there called me and they made it sound like a
great place.
And so when I went out there,
uh,
drove out there with my three boxes of household goods and it is just a country
down with 50,000 college students.
And,
uh,
it was a great opportunity,
but college station was not for me and the war had kicked off.
And so I finished school in three years and,
uh,
got out of there.
And then how did you go from,
at what point did you tell him you wanted to join the navy?
So I,
you know,
going out there,
I had had about a 75%,
uh,
had already made my decision that I wanted to switch over to the seals.
Even if you looked at it from a time perspective,
had I gone to TBS and then,
you know,
officer of tree course,
it would've taken me the same amount of time to get to a seal team.
And so it just made common sense.
I'd worked with a few seals during the workups workups,
uh,
at first three comp time.
Uh,
you know,
they were older,
statistically more highly educated,
more physically fit,
and the biggest part,
they were part of Socom and they had the money.
I was still carrying an m 1682 as a recon marine.
Mrs Neiber.
Um,
we just didn't have the money.
We didn't have the gear.
And so,
uh,
you never see seal switch from the seal teams to Regan,
but you see a lot of recon marines switchover to SOCOM units.
They needed to go seal green.
Baret have a lot of them went PGA,
which for the listeners is a air force para rescue jumper.
Um,
so I did go to Marino cs and I got to tell you again,
that was a challenge.
Uh,
lost,
I think I went in and browned probably one 85 and lost about 20 pounds that he
didn't need to uh,
to lose.
And so that was a summer in Quantico and I was impressed.
And you talk about maintaining that standard,
that that quality spread that the Marine Corps does so well,
especially within their officer ranks.
That's the reason.
Yeah.
How long has it,
how long has marine corps,
ocs?
Three months.
And how did,
if you,
if you knew you wanted to go in the navy,
how can they send you to a Marine Corps?
Ocs?
So the me set program,
you actually go to ocs after the or during the first summer of your freshman
year and got it.
You still come back as a sergeant?
I was a sergeant at that time.
Uh,
continue towards your degree in what you finish your degree.
Then you get,
you get commission one year prior.
And here's,
here's the funny thing.
So one year prior to graduating and said,
hey,
uh,
went to my marine officer,
instructor,
who's a major,
who's a prior enlisted guy himself,
great guy.
Uh,
I'm like,
I think I want to go seals.
He's was like,
okay,
let's put it back at you.
It was like,
Hey,
the military is going to get their pound of flesh from either way,
do what you want to do.
Uh,
the commanding officer was marine colonel did not see it that way.
I was dislocated.
So during the process of the trade to believe the court pretty much,
and,
and I literally hate you,
the major prep me yet.
He's like,
Hey,
just listen to what he has to say.
Nod your head and just step out of the room.
I got Ya.
And so the inner service transfer was almost immediate.
That approved.
It was,
that was that easy of a process.
But then they told me I needed to attend something called out many buts that
summer of my junior year.
Um,
and,
and so when I show up,
you have about 35 midshipmen from naval ROTC units,
the Naval Academy,
and then one sergeant in his marine Charlies.
And it is,
you know,
Khakis,
Khaki top with a,
uh,
blue bottoms with the red stripe and,
um,
amongst 34 guys in white.
And I just stuck out and it was God.
So God,
he always in our course and um,
you know,
I was still very much a sergeant,
so they did love me towards the end because like they said,
hey,
we need this done.
I would step up y'all,
hey fellas,
let's get this done.
And,
um,
the guy sort of rallied around me and,
uh,
you know,
low and behold,
at the end of that,
I had a,
a spot waiting for me when I graduated and it didn't hurt that,
uh,
the,
the CEO of buds was a former marine himself.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
That's,
that's awesome.
That's a good way to get that in there.
The prior marines that come into teams are always got a little extra squared
away inside them in their brain.
And Bud's any factor of buds.
Does anyone goes through buzzes and say it's an a,
it's a non factor in a non factor.
What was the biggest factor you had?
Patients,
it was patients.
I asked you about patients and snipers going,
what were you in face or with you in sniper school?
I was still new guy.
Uh Oh yeah,
that's right.
So you stepping into a community that I highly admired that I want to be a part
of was the easy part.
It was some of the instructors had a very,
they were,
they were very artistic and getting under your skin.
What year is it now?
Subset now when is it?
Oh yeah.
Oh it's,
it's game time.
And in fact I think you,
you,
you were deployed right around that time.
Yeah.
Well I was deployed in 2003,
2004 my first deployment to Iraq.
Yeah.
Cause your counterpart,
your,
your sister platoon commander visited me in buds calling.
It was right before you guys went.
Oh,
right on.
And um,
which I have a funny story about a Johnsy when you came to speak to us.
Um,
so do you know it just
the,
the patients are going through the process you went through Josie.
You did.
Okay.
I did not remember that.
That's weird.
Um,
so you,
you had,
you were a little bit impatient of going through buds.
Like basically you're saying,
aw man,
I'm ready to get in the game.
And they're like,
okay,
take this,
sweep this grinder and do all this dumb stuff that you have to do.
Yeah.
Oh,
100%.
When people ask me,
cause people ask me all the time,
Hey,
I'm 33 years old,
I want to go in the military.
Do you think it's a good idea?
I'm always like,
here's the problem.
The problem is you're 34 years old.
There's some real benefits to that in that you're mature and you are smart and
you have knowledge about the world.
Here's the bad part.
You're mature,
you're smart,
you have no one's about the world.
Because when they're like,
hey,
we want you to do this completely ridiculous task that makes no sense
whatsoever.
You're not going to feel like doing it and you're going to have to do it.
And that's going to grate on you even more.
When I was 18 years old and I joined the navy,
it literally didn't matter what they made me do.
I would like,
well,
when you just said,
when you,
when you joined the Marine Corps and when,
when Ben said to you,
hey look,
you can just do what they tell you to do and life's going to be good and you
like,
I f I didn't,
no one told me that.
But when I got to boot Camp I was like,
oh,
I do what they tell me to do in life is going to be good.
That's what's going to happen.
So I was like,
Oh,
you fold my underwear,
whatever.
Clean the toilets.
Hey,
let's do this.
And that's a lot easier when you're 18.
The news when we were 34 a lot easier.
It is.
And you know,
it's not so much what they tell you to do.
They tell you what to do,
but they want to see if you perform.
It's not that we're trying to create robots and you know,
a lot of people,
you have to demystify that.
Uh,
about the military but buds is just a long process and then while we're going
through it,
they're telling us stories about what you guys are doing overseas and or you
know,
we had one seal pass away in Afghanistan at the time.
Someone received a navy cross in front of us and the whole time you want to be
those guys,
not the metals or any of that,
but you want to be the gladiator in the arena and you know you have 12 more
months of training before you can even show up to a CLT.
The other,
the other big thing,
and you knew this because you'd been in the Marine Corps,
the other big thing that people don't understand is the fear that we all had,
that this thing was going to end and we weren't going to do anything.
That was the biggest fear I had was this war is going to happen.
It's going to be over in three months and I won't have deployed and off to do
the rest of my navy career.
Never have go,
never,
never go into combat.
Which was the neck,
the biggest nightmare I could imagine and total nightmare
that would have been,
it's the same for the guys that were in the Gulf War,
you know that certain platoons got to go over there and they sat behind thinking
they were going to backfill them in the war was going to be a long war and then
it's over and what six days,
I had a master sheet friend that was on the last plane to v the last platoon
going to Vietnam and the and the plane got shot down and they didn't go.
So I can be a total nightmare for them,
but it's hard for people to understand that mentality of how you want to go and
it's just the way it is.
Man.
I wish there was some nice thing to say about it or some psychological way to
explain it away.
Like,
Hey,
it's just a no.
It's like,
I'm just going to say the way it is.
When you're young and you're in the military,
you want to go to war.
That's all there is to it.
I'm sorry I am.
That's the way it is.
You believe you believe in what you were doing?
There's a sense of purpose.
And again,
it is counterintuitive that anyone would want to go to combat.
I'm super stoked that you feel that way.
I'm going to here to tell you and Mitt to you that like,
I just wanted to go to war.
I actually,
another old Vietnam Guy,
he,
when he left seal team one,
he goes,
I joined the navy in 1970 so I could kill people from my country.
And I was like,
Oh yeah,
I know what he's talking about.
You know,
the funny thing is you start to love it.
You start to love.
Oh yeah,
that's not a bad thing.
You know,
funny enough,
I took a job right when I retired at Texas a and m system was the director of a
veteran services for all 12 campuses.
But,
uh,
there was this sort of old hen that a mother hen,
that dude that just didn't really like me,
you know,
she,
she leans in,
she's like,
what is the worst part about war?
And,
uh,
I look at her and say that it has to end and just walked right up and you could
hear the,
it's,
it's the classic line that they got right.
And apocalypse now is when Colonel Kilgore is like,
he just,
he's distraught.
He's talking about napalm in the morning and that smell,
that gasoline smell,
the whole hill smelled bike victory
and someday this war is going to end.
And that's the worst thing he can think of because hey man,
he's a battalion commander of the Cavalry Unit,
Vietnam.
He's God,
he's still on top of the world.
He's on top of the world.
There's nothing more important in the world to him ever.
He can't even imagine it.
And he's depressed that someday the war's going to end
fired up.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So,
so where were we?
So you get done with buds buds.
The biggest thing that people always ask about the physical part of buds,
you're in good shape.
No factor.
Yes.
Is it physically exhausting?
Of course you get tired.
You know what it is.
I'll also is a,
it's an,
it's an opportunity to actually start segmenting your reputation.
And again,
I was very much still a sergeant in the instructors love me because I would
rally the boys even,
you know what I like to call a healthy appetite or healthy disrespect for
authority is to get the guys fired up against them a little bit.
Yeah,
for get and pay a little bit.
You,
you'd see what's working and what's around the board so and again,
you know,
got the fire in the gut.
The boys love me.
They rallied around me.
Officer,
you've got the fire of the gut.
Yeah,
I haven't heard that too much.
Have you heard that too much?
You don't?
I don't know.
I haven't heard that too much.
I a caveat or what is it called out of,
forget what it's called,
but I had one of my buddies texted me.
The day you,
you're making it sound like buds is super easy.
It's not easy.
And I was like,
no,
no.
Let me let me correct myself.
I'm not saying buds.
It's easy.
Like you said,
buds is hard.
It's physically hard.
The hardest thing to me,
I think physically is that it goes on day after day after day,
after day after day.
And so when you're doing a four mile time Braun,
which should be pretty easy because in first phase you've got 32 minutes to do
that.
That's a long,
that's a slow pace.
Even for a grown man,
Even for a big guy,
that's a slow pace.
But when you've done whatever,
8,008 count bodybuilders the day before,
and then you got up at three in the morning and you did 8 million flutter kicks,
and then you go out and get on the beach and you do a timed run in soft sand
with boots on,
it's not easy.
And that's what,
that's what trips people up.
I think the grind,
the one thing too,
for me that was that it was a driver is,
uh,
there was no way that I was going to disrespect the marine reconnaissance
community.
No Way.
There are some warriors.
I mean,
there was a lot of warriors within that community.
And so that was always over my head.
No way was I going to ring that bell.
That would just be a complete,
a complete,
utter lack of respect for the community I came from.
They're quitting and buds is really hard to understand.
And I,
I had like a,
I had like a midlife crisis several months ago about,
because some people that I knew about and that I've talked to had quit and,
and like I didn't get it.
And,
and there's been guys from the Marine Corps that have gone through that.
I've been like,
oh,
that's awesome.
And then they quit and you're,
you're thinking yourself,
how does this even happen?
So I'm 100% on board with the thought that no one knows who's gonna make it
through.
No one knows.
Like you can't say,
this guy's gonna make it,
he's a stud or this person's not gonna make it because they're weak.
You,
you literally don't know.
Now could I bat 60% maybe 70% maybe,
but there's no way you could make a sure thing.
There's not one person in the world that you could say,
this guy is going to make it through buds 100% there's no person in the world
you can say that about that.
I've,
that I know of.
The most humbling lesson I learned in bugs and,
and you're going to find this funny,
was I went through bugs with a guy named Ryan job.
Sound familiar?
And again,
remember I'm a,
I'm still really fired up a marine sergeant that's just pinned on bars and,
uh,
from judging a book by its cover,
you look around and you're like,
you're not going to make it.
Everything was sloppy about them.
And I even told him no one point,
I'm like,
hey man,
you're not going to make it.
You should quit now.
And just to watch him in,
the instructor's zeroed in on him and the kid had no quit.
And even at the end of hell week,
having been beat more than anyone in that class,
the instructor is actually pulled him aside and they said,
hey,
you're good to go.
Like,
we've thrown everything at you in the kitchen sink and you stood shrong you're
going to be a great seal.
And I've watched that and I'm like,
Oh man,
I,
who am I to judge who's going to make it and who's not?
And that was a,
that was a life lesson.
I still remember now.
It wasn't until Ramadi that I,
I apologize to Ryan who sort of giggle and he's like,
yeah,
I know.
He was like,
you all thought it wasn't gonna make it.
Yeah.
Like you said though,
no,
zero quit,
zero quit.
And doesn't matter what you do to me,
I'm going to be right here.
So then you get done.
You get done with buds.
So I came and talked to your Jaci class.
What'd I talk to you guys about?
You said you,
uh,
you and,
um,
your task and commander.
Okay.
Came and talked about the deployment is,
okay,
awesome.
But there's a,
a narrow,
it's on the second deck,
the classroom for junior officer training course,
which I eventually took over from,
for life.
Uh,
later on.
there's a narrow passageway and,
uh,
this task unit commander,
for Jocko Jocko coming off as a platoon commander tour had this,
uh,
we're,
we're standing like this and they created a little lane.
And as each of us walk through Jocko with lean in and basically make you shimmy
through,
not with these guys and that right off the bat,
like,
this guy isn't a hole.
I'm like,
screw this guy now you want us to listen to you and what I mean naturally,
hey,
he's a physically intimidating dude,
but like you,
you really like screw that guy,
man.
I don't remember that at all.
I'm sorry bro.
I was really fun with new guys though.
It didn't,
it didn't stop there and we'll get to the next and counter
and then he showed up and you went right to the tee.
You when you go right to team three after that I did showed up in November of
2004.
And um,
there was three slots open for jails immediately.
And uh,
they went to a all naval academy guys,
cause I got stuck in ops,
uh,
working with a great guy.
Um,
right on that we both know and I absolutely looked out for me and so sent me to
a free fall right away.
And then when I finished that up,
he's like,
Hey,
do you want to go join the boys overseas?
Cause team through was deployed at the time.
I'm like,
yeah.
So it was,
you know,
shortly after,
uh,
December found myself on a plane and arrived in Baghdad and balling.
I was finally in the game.
I was there.
That's half the battle and I loved it.
Yeah.
And then what were you doing?
Just tagging along with the boys.
So yes,
they give you some strange,
the job description,
but it just meant hang out and wait to go on all this.
So working in the,
uh,
the jock a naturally as an assistant operations officer,
but,
uh,
there was another seal team that was there.
I remember they were,
do,
do deployed alongside seal team three and um,
fell in with the,
the platoon commander,
uh,
quickly and he's like,
hey,
jump on the,
you're a 50
cal gunner,
uh,
when we go out,
just watch us do our thing.
Uh,
you know,
set up a court on,
uh,
w with the vehicles and slowly learn.
And so every time they would go out and I would jump in the,
the uh,
the Humvee as a 50 cal gunner and,
uh,
I was in heaven.
I was an absolute,
that is freaking stoked.
And then you came back so he could come home from that deployment and then you
get put into it.
Is that,
is it,
did you get a platoon the next time where you like did you get stuck being ops
again in that task unit?
So I get,
yeah,
I got stuck there.
This is like good deals for good seals.
Yeah,
it got stuck as to you.
Charlie,
uh,
opposite,
gets some.
And so again,
the other slots were full.
Uh,
I'd have to wait for an Ayc.
It would mean I still get to deploy.
I actually,
it's a double benefit when you look at it.
The end of the day I actually get to deployments.
Those guys,
after they're done with their assistant platoon commander door step,
I have to go elsewhere.
And so it actually was a blessing in disguise.
And then,
okay,
so you're in that task unit.
And interestingly,
that task unit is in the book,
extreme ownership in a very short passage.
And I was looking at it to think about what,
what we said about it,
but there was a task unit at seal team three at the time,
and the task unit commander and one of the platoon commanders,
they didn't get along.
They had issues with each other and they couldn't,
they couldn't get,
they couldn't put it aside,
they just couldn't put it aside.
And even the commanding officer,
again,
this is in the book,
and the commanding officer said,
hey look,
I'll tell you what,
I know you two have issues because they had both come to him separately and I'm
probably screwing up the story.
But it was something like this.
They both came to him and said,
hey,
look,
I can't work with this guy.
And the other guy says,
And he brings them together and says,
look,
it's Friday by Monday.
Come in here and tell me how you two are gonna work together.
Understand?
And they're like,
yeah,
I got it sir.
They come in Monday and what do they say?
I can't work with him.
And he goes,
okay,
you guys can't work together.
Guess what?
You're fired.
And he fired both of them,
which was a,
which was a great move actually I,
but I think it was a good move.
You know,
if you've got two people that can't figure out how to work together under the
threat of being fired from your job,
that's a real problem.
Especially if you can't substantiate it.
I mean if you can't go in there and say,
listen,
here's the reasons why I can't work with this guy.
It's this,
this and this.
Cause obviously they had the opportunity to do that.
And there are situations where you can say,
look,
I can't work with this guy.
He has a moral or he's unethical or he treats everyone horribly and I can't sit
there and watch this happen.
Like there's reasonable arguments that you could make where you literally can't
work with someone.
But when you can't even substantiate on argument as to why you can't work with
someone and then you get told,
okay I get it and I don't hear any real reasons.
So Youtube go figure it out and you come back and say,
no,
it's not happening.
It seems to me like a good movies.
Okay.
Neither one of these guys I trust to go overseas and form relationships with
other military units in foreign military units and do their job properly.
And he fired them both you somehow they said,
okay,
you know what collateral damage we're going to take Sorelli and we're gonna move
them into tasking at bruiser.
That's what they did.
And I was stoked because I wanted more people always,
you know,
cause you get another 50 cal gunner,
you get another officer,
you get another shooter,
you get it,
it's another person that's a,
it's awesome.
And I was stoked to have you coming on board and there was,
there was like a little bit of,
I mean there was,
there was drama because you know,
inside,
inside bruiser was like no drama.
Like,
we don't,
we don't play a drama.
Like we solve problems.
We keep our mouth shut.
We do what we're supposed to do.
We,
if we got problems,
we figured them out,
we straighten them out and we move on and we could see all this drama unfolding
in that other task and it,
which is not cool.
I mean you don't like seeing that at a seal team.
You want the wholesale team to be kick ass.
And so you see a task unit that's in turmoil looks like not fun to watch.
Especially cause I knew,
I basically knew every player in there.
I knew every one of those guys.
And you watch him just fallen apart and eagles are flaring up and it's just a
nightmare,
man.
It was a nightmare.
Anyways,
you get basically out of that whole catastrophe outcomes.
Mike Cirelli unitasking a bruiser and best worst deal I've ever been dealt.
Best.
Worst deal I've ever been dealt.
So you check in and I remember I was thinking to myself,
okay,
I didn't know you.
Uh,
I've looked at your record.
I knew you were in the Marine Corps.
I like,
I knew that you were going to be squared away.
That was my,
that was my,
as much as you can predict,
you know,
I was thinking,
okay,
this guy was in the marine corps,
this guy is going to be awesome.
You seem like you were serious and you want to do good job.
And,
and so I was,
my assumption was you're gonna kick ass.
However,
I had to be a little bit,
you know,
I had to do a little precautionary,
precautionary,
take some precautionary measures to make sure that you understood where I was
coming from.
You know,
I wanted to make sure you knew where I was coming from while La having a little
fun with it.
Just a little,
just a smidge.
Yeah.
So that's why,
that's why we so introducing you into the task of bringing you in.
I wanted to let you know like,
Hey,
this is where I'm at.
You know,
we don't have any drama here.
That's why.
So that's why we did the whole,
uh,
the whole briefing.
So in the mechanical,
so in the mechanical room.
So at seal team three at the time there was no ceilings in any,
they were doing this big remodel and there was no ceilings in any of the
platoons.
Spaces are tasking and spaces.
There was all just,
there was a wall with no ceilings so you could hear everything that was being
said.
And so whenever I had something legitimate,
like an issue to bring up with someone,
and it was almost,
it was at,
in fact,
it wasn't even almost always,
it was always my,
my jailers who was either life or Seth or one of the other gos.
And I'd bring them in there and I'd be like,
Hey,
here's what's going on.
Because in the mechanical room there's a loud noise and no one can hear you.
And that's the only room that's still had a ceiling for privacy,
for privacy.
It was like the cone of silence is the cone of silence.
So whenever someone was doing something that I really need to tighten up,
someone was getting out aligned and I really needed to talk to him on,
on the secret level.
And by secret,
I mean I didn't want anyone gossiping
about when I was about to say,
so I'd bring him in the mechanical room and tell him what was up.
And so that's what I,
that's how I welcome to Mike into the task unit.
Go ahead.
Now you can get out of your perspective.
Have you come out of an incident where I was wrapped up in a lot of little bit
of drama and being shifted that incident though you were just sort of like in
that group or,
or were you,
you know,
show since I was close to operations officer,
which is basically the,
the,
the guy that handles the a,
the day to day affairs,
the troop commander,
I was naturally close to him.
And if you want to step back to that task unit because it was one of the,
uh,
again,
many great leadership lessons across the course of my career,
uh,
for a new guy watching that in the seal teams,
it was,
eh,
you know,
I was questioning maybe this is not for me,
if this is the norm,
cause that this is my first experience.
So this means this is normal to me.
Um,
it just seemed like backstabbing Egos.
Uh,
one of the platoons they performed and they stayed out of the drama for the most
part.
But between this,
between commander and the,
and the task unit commander,
it was from day one,
it was just like watching a train derail.
You just sought coming in the fact that the boss laid down the rule and they
come back on Monday morning and paint him into a corner.
I don't know what they expected.
Yeah.
And they both got fired and it both affected their career.
But it was a great,
I actually,
I can say as a,
as a new guy,
it was a great thing to see in retrospect because you learn what not to do.
Yeah.
Um,
but when I was told to report into,
to Jocko,
you know,
I'm not in the best of,
uh,
of spirits tour and a knock on the door to,
to task unit bruiser and say,
Hey,
Mike's Raleigh Jocko,
oh,
I'm here to report in.
And he said,
Roger,
come with me.
And he had a sheet of paper in his hand,
principal's office.
I'm like,
Whoa,
what's going on here?
And so I follow him into everyone knows what the mechanical room is,
but nobody goes in and uh,
I mean do you just want to picture like cogs turning and it's loud.
There's steam coming out and nightmare on elm street.
That's our Fridley or did is eight word.
You actually told me to pop too.
And um,
so I popped two and you basically lay down the law of,
Hey,
I heard what ha what happens,
you have clean site here but do not bring drama into my task unit.
Here's your counseling sheet.
You've been formally counseled and uh,
pretty much left the room.
And I think I sat in the room for 30 seconds to a minute and I'm just staring at
the wall.
Like what?
Uh,
like my,
my career in the seal teams is going to be extremely short.
I'm getting it from all directions.
And what he did was you laid down the law and I understood there was just one
thing to do at that point and that was just performed.
It was performed.
Yeah.
The other backstory here is,
is that the platoon that you're talking about,
that performer,
well inside that task unit,
the platoon chief,
and because
he was,
he was one of my good friends from way back and because there's all this stray
voltage going around about whose fault this was.
And he came up to me and he goes,
hey,
you're getting Sorelli.
And I was like,
yeah.
And he goes,
he's fucking good to go.
And I was like,
check.
And that's like literally all I needed to hear because when he told me that I
knew like he's like I respect his opinion and so I actually knew you were going
to be good to go a little bit stronger than I than I gave note to now.
He was in terms of first people you meet in the seal teams was absolutely
welcoming to every new guy.
No hazing whatsoever.
You can perform as a new guy,
you're a part of this platoon,
you have a voice.
And once he found out,
cause he's a sniper found out,
uh,
I was a sniper in the Marine Corps.
He was like,
go,
Hey,
I'm,
I'm making a call,
the army right now,
go check out a suite of guns.
And I was shocked and I trained up as a sniper,
as an officer for the entire workup.
And it was because of that one guy who welcomed me with open arms.
And you know,
despite his,
his long history in the teams,
I mean,
no ego whatsoever.
These humble.
Awesome.
So you've given him that paper,
the formal counseling,
that's like a,
isn't that something you normally do if you get in trouble,
if I'm officially scolding you or represents,
so you just feed it to make a straight up impression like,
hey,
by the way,
I probably wrote in my entire naval career less than five.
I might have written three maybe.
So he didn't even do anything.
Yeah,
I know.
I had to give one to lay off one time,
like my,
my,
uh,
I Lafe Lafe Lafe did something and the Xo was like,
you need to write him up.
And I was like,
definitely sir.
And so I wrote him up in the,
and I shredded it later or whatever.
You know,
it's like not,
but there's a very few times that I actually did that.
But again,
we're getting you late.
It was pretty late.
We were going on deployment soon and so it was like,
okay,
let's,
let's get some,
you've got to set the,
set the expectations out there in the front,
you know,
we're not playing around.
And then we go on deployment,
we're going to Ramadi.
We,
well,
because before we did that,
we did assert x and all that kind of the last little bit of training.
And then we went on deployment to Ramadi.
No,
I did not.
I joined you after Ceredex.
I literally joined yet three weeks before we deploy hood.
God.
So I was that fresh tasking at bruiser,
no relationships,
uh,
with a few guys that a young new,
to buds with actually.
So remember Mark Lee and I transferred over the same time.
Yeah,
yeah.
That was after SIRTEX.
Wow.
Are you sure mark might had been before I was asking.
Okay.
Yeah,
I think mark was before.
Yeah.
Cause oh that's right.
Cause the everything fell apart and sort of next for you guys.
But you're Ceredex was before ours.
That's right.
It was.
We'd come back from Panama.
That's when the proverbial shit hit the fan within that.
Tasking.
So then Jay,
we're getting ready to go to Ramadi and what?
What'd you you,
you came,
you became,
what did you become like,
like,
cause I had a guy that was the,
the task unit ops.
Did I make you tasks?
You did assist in the office
constantly.
The motive.
That was the beginning.
I was who I was,
the ops,
but quickly became me.
Let me,
let me tell you something.
This is a,
this is a great,
a great point.
Because all that,
like basically,
you know what that is really,
it's like a test.
Like Hey,
I'm gonna write you up.
Let's see what your attitude is.
You got to use it.
You know what his attitude was like,
Roger,
I'm no drama.
Don't worry about it.
Then it's like,
okay,
you're going to work for this other guy that's probably lower in rank than you
that has been in the military for a year and you're going to work for him.
How do you,
how do you take that?
And you know what Mike's attitude was like Roger,
that I'm here to work.
Those things.
Like when you,
when those things happen you,
cause people ask me this kind of question all the time,
well you know,
someone else got promoted or someone that's got this and said,
what do you do?
Oh you work hard.
That's what,
and that's exactly what you did.
And you know,
it took a matter of days before I was thinking,
okay,
I'll give him a little bit more.
I come a little bit more.
And then very shortly thereafter it's like,
okay,
guess what?
You are ops now,
which is not like this huge,
great job,
but it's,
it's,
it's pretty significant.
Once we're on the ground in Ramadi,
there's a lot of responsibility there.
I had to count on you for a lot of stuff and because you were freaking squared
away and we're like,
okay Roger that no attitude,
nope,
never did you like I gave you.
And then we got overseas,
I remember I gave you the worst job,
which was I sent you to the TG,
right?
So the TG,
for those of you that don't know too much about the military,
there's a,
there's a headquarters above the task unit,
which is called,
it's the seal team,
but when you're on deployment it's called a task group and they have all kinds
of administrative stuff that they've got to handle.
And we,
we,
we had a great team with great support from our head shed,
but they needed people to work.
They need people to drive paperwork is basically what they needed.
And so they needed on officer to go over there for 30 days for 30 days and get,
you know,
work,
do all this paperwork.
And I had to submit an officer and I,
I sent you and there's two reasons why I did it.
Well,
number one,
the number one reason why I did it was because I knew that you'd get there and
figure things out and help us greased the skids for everything that we were
doing.
Whereas if I send someone else,
they might to be able to pull that off as well and to,
cause I knew when I get you back I could do something awesome with you,
like get you in the field,
which is what I did.
So yeah,
if you're in those situations where you feel like your,
you deserve better,
just be quiet,
suck it up,
do a good job.
And if you're,
the other part that people get paranoid about is they think,
well they won't notice me.
They think I should tell Jocko how awesome I am.
I should tell Jocko that I was in the Marine Corps.
I should tell Jocko that I,
I'm a sniper.
I should tell like,
hey,
I got a better idea.
How about you just be humble and just work.
And if you do that,
then Jocko says,
oh hey man,
this guy is squared away.
I wonder why Swiss sword away.
I look at his record,
oh,
he's in the Marine Corps.
Oh,
let me look at his record.
he uses it.
He's a sniper.
Oh,
he was in recon.
Okay,
I've got a pipe fitter here.
Cool.
I can use them.
And he's humble on top of all that as opposed to,
hey,
look at me because believe me,
there's plenty of people that come in and they want to bow up and act like
they're the baddest guy on the planet.
And it's like,
yeah,
that's a real problem.
That's a real problem because they have a big ego.
It was to the point where I knew I burn my personal capital until it was time to
rebuild.
And even before he sent money that he's asked group,
uh,
you know,
running ops quickly came apparent that the other guy that was ahead of me just
wasn't gonna cut the bill.
But a leaf had asked me if I wanted to go out and I'm like,
yeah,
man.
And everything in me wanted to go out on a mission with them because these guys
are already starting to kill.
Uh,
you know,
a lot of a combatants.
But I had work to do in terms of ops.
That jacket would pass down and I knew if I had went out,
it wouldn't have gotten done and you would elect me,
made that call.
You would have let me go.
But I,
you know,
I passed and Lafe,
we were talking about that yesterday.
I was with [inaudible],
Texas and he's like,
I remember that one thing and we knew that was a sign that you were going to get
your stuff done.
And he actually made the right call and uh,
you know,
he still brings that up.
Do they know what you were doing?
You were looking out for the task unit instead of looking out for yourself.
That's what that is.
You were looking out for the task and instead of looking at your,
for yourself,
you were taking care of what your actual job was instead of taking care of
yourself.
And that's again,
for,
for everyone.
That's a wondering like how to act.
That's how you act.
You take care of the team before you take care of yourself.
You stay humble.
You don't think that you deserve more than you're going to get.
When you get handed a shit sandwich,
take a bite,
chew it and put a smile on your face and to ask for another one and make that
one squared away too.
And that's how,
that's how you're going to get where you want to go,
which for you eventually met going to join Delta platoon.
Awesome.
Best experience I've ever had.
And again,
with a a,
a platoon that is humble and if there is a personification of that,
that is JP [inaudible] and those guys welcome me with open arms and I was taken
back by the,
uh,
by the humility.
They're,
they're just,
they're sort of,
you know,
the way I described all the opportunities,
they were like the little guy,
they were the little guy in task unit bruiser um,
in the sense that they were just quiet with what they did.
It just different personalities between Charlie and Delta and you love both
platoons,
but they had a very different style of leadership.
Um,
and you know,
I can't name any of their names cause most of them are still in active duty,
but um,
it felt like home and then being with Seth was educational given the experience
that they had gotten within those like two months that wasn't there two and a
half,
three months.
And um,
you know,
there was a steep learning curve,
uh,
after three months combat for them.
And I'm stepping in because I had to like speed up to the,
basically the speed of war because they were already there.
They had a ton
of experience at that point.
I mean he was,
it was an insane amount of experience.
The,
the,
the first,
at one point they did 24 straight patrols into the [inaudible] and get contacted
every single time.
And then one,
they didn't get contacted,
they were like way up in the northeast section and they didn't get contacted.
And then the next time they went out,
which was a day later,
they were right back in it again.
So the amount of experience that they had was just,
was,
was ridiculous.
It was ridiculous.
I remember.
So I was briefing the CG Soda and I've made that quote right there.
And I was like,
these guys have been in contact on their last 23,
um,
their last 23 operations.
And the,
the talk watch officer comes walking in,
he needs,
he's like,
sir.
I was like,
yes.
And he goes,
I just want to let you know,
uh,
decorate doors in a,
in a tech right now.
And I was like,
Roger,
that,
and I looked at the chronicity,
make that 24
and that was a,
that was,
that was pretty awesome.
We used to,
when those big,
big wigs would come to visit us in Ramadi,
we would,
we would attempt to make it all nice.
But what that looked like was so obviously
wretched that like we would,
we would say,
hey,
you know,
we've,
we've got,
we'd,
we'd lay out the,
uh,
the Mre coffee for them,
so like,
hey,
if you want a cup of coffee,
here's the Mre coffee.
And we'd make it like we were doing our best to give them the best treatment,
but like the treatment that you're gonna get,
just socks.
Cause we're out here in the middle of the and their supply chains,
not as good as it could be.
And Hey,
if you want,
hey,
we really want you to have coffee if you have it.
So here's an Mre coffee.
You can mix it up here and get some.
And then when they left,
we cleared out the ass black closet
via coffee machines back up.
The funny thing is,
um,
you talking about the task group and during my time there is a for those big
waves that come in and he said it was such a deviation from what soft was doing
in Iraq prior to that.
And you know,
I like to,
you know,
use Colonel Mcfarland who you need to have on the show was going to Boswell.
He's retired now,
attend general,
uh,
former commander of the a one one a brigade combat team is that he realized we
weren't winning.
We are not winning a to teen,
continue operations as we have been doing is the wrong call and things need to
change.
And even at the task group,
uh,
loved the commander over us,
because it was a deviation from what every other seal team had done.
You could see him struggling with whether it was the right call.
And I remember a few times he called me in,
um,
to ask my opinion about what was going on,
but he wasn't really looking for an answer.
He was using me just as a springboard for his own thought process until I would
talk very little and he would just sorta keep on talking and it,
I mean,
he had a very solid,
uh,
sort of thought process along the lines of how he justified it and ultimately,
you know,
looked out for you and the rest of the task units.
Yeah.
And they allowed us to look out for all the conventional forces that were
working with Zach,
the the one one eight d in the first of five or six and the one,
three,
seven and three,
eight marines and all those guys that were on the ground with us there who we
were able to help out as much as,
as much as possible,
only because we got clearance to do those operations,
which as you said was,
uh,
was outside the norm,
outside the norm,
day time operation,
staying out in the city,
supporting conventional forces of which freaks some people out.
Like why would you be supporting them?
They should be supporting you.
It's like,
well now they've got whatever,
a thousand soldiers and they're taking down a giant part of the city and we can
help protect them.
So we are a supporting element,
but it's going to be,
it's going to have big impact.
So it was,
uh,
it was awesome.
So when you got,
when you got out to Corregidor where the first of the five oh six,
how awesome is first of the five.
Oh,
how awesome is first.
The Bible is the first of them,
five oh six from the top down.
We're hardcore warriors.
Some of the strongest leadership.
So now a major general,
a raw material.
I'm sorry,
Ron Clark was the battalion commander at the time to Lieutenant Colonel Dave
Womack.
I mean,
I've never seen in my 20 years a stronger,
uh,
soft conventional force relationship other than Ramani.
I mean,
it was a textbook case of unity of effort.
Nobody worked for the other,
but they all worked in unity towards the same,
uh,
and,
and state and it was beautiful.
And Ron Clark,
of course,
you know,
Seth and all the boys,
it's set that relationship up.
They'd done a wonderful job and,
um,
the fact that,
you know,
I got out there before he bestowed the first of the five oh six spade on them
and he,
you know,
like I was there when he got bestowed upon us,
uh,
a just,
I mean,
I need to qualify this,
you know,
getting the tried,
it was one of the biggest things,
one of the biggest accomplishments of my life,
but the,
it was just like a different sense of pride.
Then almost rates up there that this badass lieutenant colonel that that had
been,
uh,
you know,
in the soc for so long,
uh,
bestowed a infamous,
you know,
a symbol on our shoulders and said,
hey,
you wear this and combat.
And that was,
I mean,
there's very few words to describe how that felt.
I was,
um,
like you said,
there were the relationship between the,
between everyone,
between us,
between everyone at the one one.
And it was just freaking awesome.
And I don't know if we'll ever be able to capture that and describe it.
Um,
but man,
it was,
it was awesome and what they did for us and when we did whatever we could for
them and what they did for us,
man,
was just the sacrifices that they made and the,
and the effort that they put forth to support what we doing.
It was,
it was,
it was awesome.
It was just awesome.
Talk about,
um,
just give like,
hey,
this is what we were doing so people can hear from your perspective.
Like,
again,
you know,
you don't need to get into tactics that,
but just,
hey,
just a general,
this is what we were doing.
We were covering and moving with the first of five or six.
That's how I put it.
We were recovering and moving again all in the sit in pursuit of the same goal
is when Ramadi and um,
we could have stuck with the status quo with the nightly,
a direct action rates,
but it just had little impact compared to what the,
uh,
the conventionals were doing and they were going to go out.
So we really utilize the skill set that was unique to the seal teams and that
was the sniper Overwatch and uh,
you know,
those positions,
their sniper positions cause we would,
again,
we defied sort of traditional tactics of those two to four guys that went out,
maybe six guys in a sniper hide and we went out in force.
Yeah.
Fighting positions,
fighting positions.
Because shortly after,
the first few kills from our,
uh,
our snipers,
um,
it quickly turned into a battle position because then they can sort of
triangulate where you're at based off the bodies lying on the ground and they
had become very good at it.
But we would move out,
uh,
ahead of the frontline trace of the five oh six set up a sniper,
Overwatch mutually supporting sniper,
Overwatch,
uh,
to really,
protect me.
A conventional is doing major clearances throughout them,
the lob district,
and it was highly successful.
Yes.
Did it meet?
We operated during the,
uh,
the days?
Sometimes it did.
Uh,
most often we would infiltrate at night prior to,
uh,
you know,
use the advantage of [inaudible] to your unit set up prior to the,
uh,
the confessionals coming in in the early morning and starting the I the
clearance operations and then we pull out during the day or stay until night.
Um,
just to,
uh,
give herself a,
you know,
mitigate risk as best possible.
But you know,
you cannot argue the numbers don't lie.
You cannot argue with the numbers that the [inaudible] acts.
We're going down,
enemy combatants were killed,
were,
were stacking up and slowly,
you know,
taking one bite at a time of that elephant.
We,
we moved further and further into central Ramadi,
which was enemy held territory,
uh,
up until 2006 and then from the other side,
Charlie platoon was coming in from the,
from the western side of Ramadi.
And it was like,
eventually we just all met men in the middle and called it good.
So,
okay.
When you got over Corregidor,
I mean obviously you're working for stoner when you first show up there,
how's that
stoners?
Great.
I,
stoner is a very,
uh,
I don't know if the word eclectic is a good way to describe him.
So for the audience,
I mean,
Seth stone is a,
is a naval academy graduate,
highly intelligent.
And you knew the guy almost had a photographic memory.
I ended up getting his,
um,
his master's from Princeton.
So clearly three of the guys intelligent.
Um,
what,
what do you stand about?
Six,
two,
six,
three.
He was a,
he was a big dude.
He was overly aggressive.
Um,
sort of had some extra tissue above his,
uh,
his eyebrows.
It sort of made him look like a,
uh,
a caveman.
But stoner had a reputation of,
of being,
you know,
just that aggressive [inaudible] that's what was needed in that position.
But he wasn't reckless.
And let me say that he was,
he was very methodical and diligent.
Most of the decisions he made.
And,
um,
you know,
for any leader that the burden of command is,
is a lonely place.
You're tasking commander,
you know,
even though you're close with Leif and Jocko and Seth,
you're,
you're also alone and for sat out there all by himself because,
you know,
um,
Andrew taken off,
he was by himself and he really had nobody want to commence a rate.
And so I think when I get out there,
you know,
he was relieved to have a,
uh,
an officer that was a,
you know,
a little more aggressive,
um,
and confided in me.
And so I went everywhere with Seth every meeting for the first of the five oh
six.
Um,
I think he was in a sense,
relieved,
you know,
one of my strengths.
And,
and it sucks to say this was,
I was actually a very good planner,
very good planner.
You know,
I took a lot of pride in the fact that it was a sniper and so I could do a lot
of analysis,
mission analysis,
donate,
mitigate risk.
And then I was very good at knocking out the products,
uh,
almost in my own demise and the,
and we'll get to that the funny story,
but,
uh,
Seth knew he could rely on me for the little things to get that done,
to clear the way for him to focus on the more strategic picture,
what an IA at the battle of money.
And so,
um,
you know,
because I respected him for what he had done up to that point,
like very much in a sense as a young seal,
I was trying to earn his respect as well.
And I think I did that towards the end cause he knew he could rely on me.
Um,
and I think quickly out in the field and I proved my worth.
well to remember,
I'm an officer with a sniper rifle now finally in the game as well.
Um,
but we grew extremely,
extremely close to the point where he started to bounce off,
you know,
bounce a maters off me for my opinion before he weighed,
weighed in some final decisions.
Um,
and he became a brother quite frankly.
And um,
you know,
when the deployment was over,
lead the way and making sure that he was sent off out of Delta platoon and in
fine fashion,
you know,
we got them,
uh,
um,
forgetting the pistol.
But it was a,
it was a nice pistol.
It was like a $2,000 pistol.
Uh,
the boys were happy to it shit,
man.
So we made sure that we sent Seth off with as much love as he showed the,
uh,
the boys in limit.
Let me finish with Seth in that regard.
He loved,
loved
the guys.
He would hold them accountable by all means.
You know,
he was close with guys,
but he did not get in the way of him making a decision,
a right decision,
not what was best for the gas,
but what was right for the gas.
And he would make those hard decisions.
And he didn't mind being unpopular if he did.
Yeah,
I,
oh.
Um,
at some point I'll be talking a lot about him,
not now.
So
now we're almost done with deployment and,
uh,
you guys had a matter of,
I don't know what to call it in terms of number of missions left.
Might be zero,
might be one.
Might be too,
but it was almost time for everyone to start packing up and heading home.
And that didn't mean that the first of five or six was going home cause they
weren't,
didn't mean the one,
one eight d was going home because they weren't,
didn't mean that they weren't gonna stop doing it operations because they
weren't,
it didn't mean that the enemy wasn't going to stop trying to kill Americans.
And so that meant that we couldn't stop doing what we had to do until the next
seal team came in to relieve us and take our place.
So there was no,
there was no stopping.
There was no stopping until it was time to go home.
Um,
closest we were.
And,
and I remember consciously,
I said to myself,
I'm not gonna say,
hey this day we'll do our last mission.
Cause I think that's like a call me superstitious.
But that to me is like a bad luck thing.
Like Hey,
okay guys,
this is the last mission.
And even in my own mind I said okay well we'll see how this one goes and if
another mission comes up.
And so I never said to myself,
okay this day or this something we're going to stop.
And I just knew that at some point we'd have enough of the,
of the new group over,
the new team would be here and we could say,
I could say,
okay,
you know what,
we're good now and we're going home.
And I didn't want to make that a con.
I didn't want to make that like a set date,
you know,
or set time or a set number of missions.
I just said when,
when we're ready to be relieved,
we'll stop and we'll just stop and we'll,
we'll,
we'll pack up.
Cause I don't want guys out in the field thinking,
Hey,
if I can just make it through this cause that's bad or I don't want guys in the
field thinking this is the last one I got to do.
And I,
I don't want that on anyone's mind,
not even mine.
And so I even tricked myself and just said,
okay,
we're going to keep going until we've got enough strength from the other team,
then we'll just stop that when that day comes.
Yeah.
So you kept operating in and everyone did kept operate,
kept going and
it was still,
despite the significant impact there had been on the enemy,
the enemy was still bringing it and they were starting to get a little bit more
desperate
and because we had really shut down a lot of their movement.
So they were starting to really try and strike back significantly when they
could.
Okay.
Uh,
so basically,
almost every time that
we went out into,
into Ramadi,
it was on at this point.
So
September 29th,
2006.
Okay.
You guys were doing another,
another operation in support of the first of five Oh six operation now Kentucky
jumper in the heart of the melodic district right by the,
uh,
the stadium.
Um,
we had inserted the,
uh,
the night before,
again in an area we had operated multiple times before.
We knew it like the back of her hand.
We had taken multiple positions in that area.
It on this specific one,
we had taken a very dominant building and when I say dominate in terms of high
device,
we,
we had the height over any other building and we were,
has diligent and methodical as we were with any other mission.
Um,
and uh,
shortly after sunrise we were engaged with the enemy first and the five oh six
had come into clear,
uh,
several sectors of them,
lob district and uh,
I think,
uh,
by noon,
um,
myself and another seal sniper had the need for gas and um,
you to add a sort of laid down and get some rest.
Cause we'd been up for close to 24 hours and Mikey and I,
uh,
were holding security and Mike,
he actually jumped on my sniper rifle to get some gun time and there was a seal
to his left three feet and that was three feet to his right.
And of course one of the things as a young guy,
and I realize now as I just always pushed to the edge,
it's sometimes to take care of the guys,
you have to take care of yourself.
And I just didn't learn that early on.
So what,
I'd always try to stay awake and I try to sleep as little as possible because I
thought it had to be there,
you know,
in case they needed me to make a decision when in reality they didn't need me
there to make a decision.
They had it and I was very replaceable.
But when you're young,
you don't always realize that until I was in and out of sleep,
you know,
Bobby sitting on the ground,
like he was sitting in a chair and Mikey and I were in conversation basically
going home cause we knew that was more the last missions.
And Mikey was excited because he was going to sniper school.
I don't know if you remember that you guys had lined that up.
Um,
he had been a machine gunner.
most of the,
uh,
well all the deployment located right next to JP who was the appointment.
And so that was Mikey's job was to Overwatch.
Like Saint Michael,
Overwatch,
JP in case they ran into enemy contact and they would be the first ones in.
Mikey would lay it down in my,
he had laid it down on multiple,
multiple occasions before.
Um,
and then the other thing we were talking about,
uh,
cause he was dating a girl and we were tying,
now that me,
he knew I was excited because my daughter at the time was two years old.
And,
uh,
you know,
I don't think I had talked to my family much on that deployment because we were
just so busy.
And that,
that's sort of my style too is once I'm deployed is it was easier for me not to
talk to my family cause it was actually a distraction because it,
it would,
it would mess with my mind.
So you knew the mission was to get home to your family as quickly as possible.
And the best way for me to do that,
I'm not saying it was the right way,
um,
was to focus on what I needed to do and it had 100% of my attention cause I
would not,
you know,
for the life of me,
I would not allow one of my guys to get killed him.
But unfortunately that's out of our control.
It's born in wars,
not clean,
but a mid day,
um,
you know,
contacted,
died down.
There was still movement,
not there.
But,
uh,
during the conversation,
um,
a,
a grenade had come over the roof and,
um,
again,
I was in and out of sleep,
but what really sort of snap me too and heart was racing right away was Mikey
snapped up.
I remember he was in a seat.
The grenade had come over the roof and he hit him in the chest
and bounced on the ground right in front of them.
And now there's a,
there's a lot of accounts out there that are wrong.
Saw some,
uh,
other seal speaking to a crowd about this.
You know,
that there was a,
uh,
entrance to the rooftop,
that stairwell that would go down in the main,
uh,
main,
building.
And that wasn't true.
We were actually like 15 meters from that stairwell at the very edge of the roof
closest to the street.
When Mikey,
I say Mike,
you had the greatest chance of getting it away is that all he had to do was dive
in the other direction and he'd most likely to take a little shot.
And I looked at the bottom of the feet into the calves,
but he would have gone home.
And,
um,
the thing that amazes me is,
uh,
you know,
I'm not the dullest tool in the shed neuroma in the sharpest,
but the cognitive ability to assess what just had happened and the potential
outcomes that if he chose self preservation,
which is not a wrong call,
um,
that the seal to his left and myself would he just ate.
And the grenade in the face completely just done
and the other seal to his left head,
kids as wall.
And,
um,
you know,
you,
you play this over in your head and trust me,
I play it every day.
And the first thing I think about when I wake up is this Mikey and my kids.
And the last thing I think about when I go to sleep,
it's Mikey and my kids.
And the reason I say that is there's a picture of,
of Mikey on my wall and you know,
it's the iconic picture of Mikey with Seth and another seal in the background
with the yellow smoke.
And He's carrying the,
uh,
the machine gun.
You had,
um,
yelled grenade.
Okay.
And then,
um,
yeah,
he did,
he dove down on it.
And I'm not to add humor to the situation,
but it's almost like that scene from a snatch where,
you know,
the guys are frozen.
It has a,
as the shotgun going off and they say you sit there with a stupid look on her
face.
I probably sat there with this stupid look on my face because one,
we,
you know,
we're in the heat mid day,
we'd been up 24 hours or exhausted and um,
it just happens so fast.
And Mikey just took action in a matter of milliseconds.
I mean,
he assessed the situation,
he knew the outcomes and he made the most selfless decision that anyone can ever
make.
There's no walking away from that.
And I know that there's,
there's some people that have walked away from jumping on a grenade,
but those are,
those are statistical anomalies.
And,
um,
it went off and,
uh,
by him smothering it,
it finalized the grenade blast to the sides towards,
uh,
the sealed to his left to myself.
And we almost had mere wounds like through and through,
in,
in both legs.
And you know,
I'd never been that close to an explosive.
We,
we,
we are,
we work with explosives all,
all the time within the seal teams,
but we are very diligent about mitigating risk and the parameters that you have
to be so far from the,
uh,
the explosives.
The thing actually picked me up and flip me over
and,
um,
I just,
I could feel the pain you people talk about,
uh,
if your shot or you're wounded,
like you don't feel it,
the adrenaline takes over.
That ain't the case.
It was immediate hot metal burning inside my legs or through through wounds,
just bleeding.
So at the time I didn't know if I had legs,
I couldn't even,
I didn't even want to look.
So I'd put my head sort of forehead on the,
uh,
the dusty a rooftop and just took that big sort of bite eight the pain and I'm a
third or fourth seal was already moving towards that direction.
Um,
he'd been affected by the blast as well.
Didn't take any SRAP metal,
but it rattled all of us.
And,
uh,
looked at Mikey,
whose head was turned towards me and I yelled,
Mikey,
Mikey.
And it was just lifeless.
And,
um,
so the,
the,
the next decision was the next thing that happened is we start to get lit up by
any enemy machine,
gun fire,
all chaos breaking out.
It's pure chaos,
pure,
a pure hell.
The Iraqi soldiers on the roof with us,
except for one who's close to us,
but he was actually stricken and fair in the fetal position.
They all ran off the roof and left us.
So you've got one critically,
mortally wounded to somewhat out of the fight that can't stand up.
And then the third is dealing with,
uh,
with Mikey.
And so we were left pretty much,
you can say,
left to die by the Iraqi soldiers.
And so I immediately went to my,
in better to,
uh,
to Golfer Seth,
who was in a mutually supporting Overwatch position,
about 500 meters away.
And,
um,
the blast had knocked out my bitter until I'm calling finally.
You know,
I pulled it in bitter route and it's just clear screen and not turn it back on,
reset it.
But the better has to go through a loads the program.
And it takes a a minute,
let's say tops.
I didn't have a minute and so still haven't looked at my legs.
I'm looking around and I see the Iraqi soldier,
he remember his name is Mohammed,
actually spoke English and uh,
he's in the field position.
I mean,
he's just stricken by fair.
And so I get up to run over to him and as I stand up to run,
I just go right down.
We'll literally on my face,
the legs just wouldn't work.
And,
uh,
again,
sort of eat the pain,
um,
which glad to do,
give them what my he's going through right now and what are you doing?
Did for us.
And I crawl over there and the Iraqi soldiers used Motorolas and Seth add Iraqis
with him as well.
And so,
uh,
I actually,
called out to Seth.
Seth eventually got on that Motorola.
Um,
and then I said,
hey,
were were to hit bad.
Mikey's down hard.
We need you now.
And they knew something was going on because of the,
the fires just,
you know,
hitting our building.
Um,
but you as a commander,
you have to wait.
You know,
you let,
let,
let the situation find out what your,
let your,
uh,
your assistant platoon commander call back and give you a sit rep at what's
going on.
He's probably hear on the radio trying to find out.
Um,
but I got back to him and probably within a minute after the whole,
a grenade blast had gone off and set,
set,
hold on,
we're coming.
And um,
so I crawled back to where Mike is at,
the four seals,
dragged him away from the wall.
Um,
and then,
um,
he's trying to work on and I told that guy,
I'm like,
Hey,
get on the machine gun.
Cause remember Mikey carries the machine,
got no's right there and he starts to lay down return fire.
And um,
it seemed like ages before Seth got there.
But finally some Iraqi soldiers would come up and they're starting to return
fire.
But you know,
it probably only took Seth five minutes,
but you've got to remember,
Seth and all those guys were set up within their position.
They weren't ready to move,
so they had to leave a lot of stuff behind the,
they,
you know,
sometimes you're not wearing your,
your kit because it's so hot and you're there for,
it was what a 48 hour operation.
You just,
you're not always wearing your kid.
So they have to throw in their kit,
probably an eight and get to us.
And then when they move into the street,
what happens?
The enemy shifts father under fire.
And,
um,
you know,
we didn't have our morphine kits and this was a problem with sort of the process
of how that works.
If you remember,
we'd sent home the guy who was signed for him about a week earlier.
And so I remember,
uh,
I finally had the courage to look in my legs.
I didn't expect to see anything there.
And there was two,
two legs,
very bloody,
uh,
ACU pants,
but they were there and that was sort of a,
uh,
a relief in a sense.
Okay.
My legs are there,
they're just not working right now.
And I went to grab from my morphine and it was gone.
And so the other seal and I are are,
you know,
we're in pain but okay,
no more moving on.
Um,
Seth eventually gets there and uh,
they start working on Mikey.
They didn't know the building where in,
in,
uh,
and apparently again,
got to love the,
I think you actually activated the,
uh,
the Bradleys in medicine on the backside of the building,
a completely different street.
I don't know.
Again,
there was,
there was some confusion about where to go and I did my best to clear that up
from what I remember,
which I don't remember very well.
Well,
the two of the guys from [inaudible],
uh,
element grabbed me and I led them through the stairwell down there was an
adjacent door to a building behind them in the backyard.
So we went through that building to the road that was on the other side of
parallel road from the road we were operating on.
And it was a,
it was a main road and they throw the other wounds,
healing myself in there.
And then the guy who was carrying Mikey,
uh,
brings Mikey into the,
the Bradley fighting vehicle.
And,
um,
we take off and that guy,
the look on his face was pure exhaustion.
Now,
within the military,
we always,
you know,
we,
we trained at the buddy carry and we do it as part of like physical training,
but you're also rigid when you're carrying your buddy and he's got his hand in
your back.
And Mikey was not a small boy,
you know,
easily,
probably to 10.
He's about six,
two,
six,
three.
And this guy,
uh,
who carried was,
I mean he's a fiscal stud and he was exhausted.
And uh,
we talked about it years later cause he sorta put Mikey down in the Bradley v
Vehicle and he sat down and just sorta was exhausted and sat there and I yelled
at him,
I'm like,
Hey,
what are you doing,
you know,
start CPR.
And he sorts snap to and,
uh,
started CPR.
You know,
he actually came to me,
here's the late.
Um,
and he's like,
man,
I'm really sorry about that.
I'm like,
brother,
you don't have to apologize.
You had just carried him,
you know,
probably a hundred meters with combat equipment on and you just,
you weren't with,
you took a second to recover to that.
It's not your fault,
but everyone finds fault and that day and everyone feels bad.
Jp who should have been there,
uh,
but had cut his finger if you remember,
wasn't there.
And um,
yeah,
it was a,
you know,
you talked about the relationship with the 506.
Again,
it seemed like ages from the,
the Bradley to get from our position in central Ramadi Mylab to uh,
the,
uh,
curricular aid station.
And I do remember,
uh,
when I got there,
the,
uh,
the medic gave me a little shot of morphine and uh,
like three minutes go by and talk about losing your composure gave in,
I'm in freaking pain and I,
I regret saying this,
it was just like stupid things you say when things are going wrong and I grabbed
him by the collar.
I'm like,
I'm a navy seal and you've got to ramp that shit up.
And you know,
I can tell the look of sort of frustration as I,
he comes back and sticks me and finally like the morphine heads and the pain
subsided.
But what I remember vividly is one,
they had very little capability for surgery,
in fact not at all.
And they had a purpose and a two 40,
a 46 is we're inbound and get us and who shows up?
Dave Womack,
Criminal Mcfarland,
I'm sorry,
Colonel Law,
Ron Clark and the senior leadership from the first of the Volvo six.
In fact,
there was probably a hundred soldiers out there and so they bring us out in the
stretchers were re strapped down and um,
Dave Womack has some leaves cause remember it's still mid day and he puts them
on me,
Wayne on the stretcher.
And uh,
I flew off with those Oakleys and if you know,
the army,
they don't get good gear,
especially in the infantry.
That guy just gave me his like eye protection that if flew off with,
but they saw us off.
And,
um,
next thing I know,
I am ended up in a Al out to get him a Tq Tq,
uh,
for surgery.
And again,
who's waiting for me?
Um,
rob your counterpart and,
uh,
all the boys.
And so the,
uh,
you know,
before they rush into surgery and put us under rob was there,
but they thought,
and in retrospect to,
you know,
I still struggle with this because I was almost upset it at a time and it was
almost like rubbing a dog's face in his own feces for taking a crap on the
carpet is they thought we would want to see Mikey.
And,
um,
so they laid both of us right by Mikey,
who was declared deceased by this point.
It was just almost like a point of shame,
a point of utter shame.
And,
uh,
I just couldn't even look,
you know,
the other seals and tears.
I'm in tears,
but I just couldn't look.
And I know they had nothing but the best intent,
but at the time it was just,
it was like,
I don't want to see this.
I know what I did.
I know what happened.
Um,
so they did that,
that give us about five minutes and then a Russ in a surgery.
And,
uh,
next thing I know,
I wake up and,
uh,
Baghdad and uh,
go through a another procedure and then prep to get the medivac to Germany,
um,
to,
to go through another,
a procedure.
And,
um,
the great thing is,
you know,
bout other seal and I were together the entire time.
They gave us to,
uh,
seals to escort us.
And um,
you know,
Germany were there for I think three days and just people kept visiting and
visiting it.
And at the time it's just,
I didn't want to talk to anyone.
I did want to talk to you and Seth and that's what I talked to you for the first
time was when he got to Germany.
And um,
it's,
cause I had,
I had my sit rep to pass and I don't know how,
I'm sure because the other seal,
the fort seal on that rooftop state was Seth.
He set was aware of what had happened,
but I needed to talk to you guys to be like,
Hey,
he jumped on that thing.
And in the military when somebody jumps on the grenade,
you know what that means.
It is the most selfless act of valor that there is and it needs to be reported
because usually if the medical records check out the,
the,
the due diligence is done and it shows that it is truth.
It is a metal of honor.
And um,
I think that is where I started this citation,
uh,
to,
to get to you.
Um,
and then,
um,
you,
after the three days there,
uh,
we uh,
we up back in San Diego,
just Fyi.
The only thing you told me,
which I asked you,
I was trying to ask you questions about,
hey,
men are doing okay.
How's the other seal that's wounded?
And you just were like,
that's all you were telling me.
It was about Mikey.
That's all you were telling me.
Morphine is a hell of a drug.
They know,
man.
It's cause you,
you wanted to make sure I knew what was going on.
You wanted to make sure that what happened.
You want to make sure that I knew that you,
you didn't care about anything else,
that you were just like,
hey,
this is what he did.
This is what he did.
I'm telling you,
this is what he did.
I'm like,
I know,
man.
I got it.
I'm like,
are you okay?
He's like,
you're like,
don't care.
This is what he did.
He saved me.
He saved this guy.
He saved all three of us up there.
That was the only thing you cared about.
And so,
okay.
Then you got home and uh,
and
yeah,
I remember,
you know,
people ask me about
like,
you know,
the,
the funerals of my guys,
but I wasn't never there.
Uh,
cause I was,
you know,
we were still deployed,
but I know that this point you were,
mmm.
And I know that's a,
I can't even imagine for you what that process was like.
It was shame.
[inaudible] the,
the way Mikey passed,
it's one of the most intimate ways,
like brothers can pass
with one another.
It's,
you know,
we're,
we're out there in the conduct of a fight.
A guy get shot,
laid down fire.
It's selfless,
but when somebody makes a sacrifice but jumping on a grenade that that is,
that is a message of,
Hey,
this is my gift to you,
keep my memory alive and live well.
But to the guy that is saved,
all you feel is shame.
And I,
and I know you,
you felt the same sort of feelings is,
you know,
ultimately you are responsible for these guys.
Um,
[inaudible] I think we all conducted in our career with God help me if there
isn't anything I could have done in the planning,
it risk mitigation and preparation for this mission or during the conduct of the
mission that brings my guy's home than I am wrong and that is on me.
And so to come home,
even though everyone was,
it was so welcoming and gracious and,
and,
and caring.
It's just,
you feel this,
this like just blanket of shame in,
funny enough,
um,
when uh,
they had these buses waiting for us at Ah,
some San Diego airport cause I remember they was able to some private jet that
took us from Bethesda to,
to San Diego.
And so they loaded us up on a bus and then straight to Balboa and my ex wife and
my daughter were,
were waiting there and um,
you know,
my daughters two at the time,
but she would not come to me.
Maybe they had a little sign welcome home daddy.
And uh,
you know,
my ex wife tried,
kept trying now because I'm still on a stretcher,
uh,
try,
try to keep giving my daughter to me and she just wouldn't,
she was queen on in my ex would not come to me.
And it was just even that,
like I remember that so vividly and I think in a,
in a way,
like I held that
against my daughter for a short while.
Um,
he's like,
it was just like,
it was almost like a shunning.
Like she knew what happened.
She was like shunning me a bottom line.
She was scared.
She was a two year old
needs to be in with mom.
But,
uh,
just,
just being at the funeral and everything and just looking at it all,
you know,
watching all the seals there to,
uh,
to celebrate my life.
It just,
it felt like the eyes were on me too.
And that's a,
that's a selfish feeling.
Hey,
this isn't about you whatsoever.
But it was just this like,
how can I,
how can I let that happen?
And why didn't you jump on there?
Your name?
Like how could you not get there in time?
Very slow.
Could you not assess what are you stupid?
And I still don't have a good answer for that,
you know?
Um,
but what really just,
you know,
we talked about this,
it's like somebody needs to hold me accountable.
That's how I found.
I'm like,
somebody needs to hold me accountable.
And uh,
you know,
the boys picked me up for the funeral and of course me and the other guy pack up
the wheelchairs,
throw him in the back of the suburban and a,
when we get to the,
um,
the mass prior to the,
uh,
the funeral,
ms [inaudible] swore is waiting and you know,
I'm ready to,
to own what had happened.
And before,
you know,
I can even get the words out.
She wrapped her arms around the other seal and I and says,
I'm so happy you are home.
Thank you for being with my son.
And at that point you're like,
okay,
I have no idea what to say.
You just totally threw me off my game.
Like you should be upset.
You just lost your son and you are the banking me for being with your son and
you're telling me you are so happy that I'm home.
I can talk about like,
it felt like the ultimate mind find camp.
But that is just a testament of the family that Mikey came from.
And for the audience.
Um,
Mikey was a southern California kid.
Again,
pretty big kid,
about six to probably about two 10 dry sense of humor and was a devout Catholic
and the family still want,
I don't want you to think of this like strict religious family.
They are family but they are resolute in their beliefs and their from southern
California.
And um,
they're the most selfless family I've ever met.
And when you meet them and you spend time with them,
you quickly realize where Mikey got it.
And he went to every mass at Corregidor.
And when I say mass,
it's in a bombed out building with some military priest,
uh,
in about five people and one of which is Mikey,
passing out communion.
And he had faith and uh,
getting to know the family was actually very easy after that.
But with time,
as time went on,
you know,
uh,
you being to feel like you were a reminder of their son and not the best light.
And so I think over time I,
you know,
I pulled away from the family to give them their,
their rest cause at some point they have to put it down and move on with their
lives.
And I don't know if that's the right call him.
Man.
I still struggle with that today.
But I mean I love the family.
Uh,
even there was a sense of guilt from my parents when they met their parents.
Just how good people and you feel like why their son and not ours are my,
my parents are thankful.
Don't get me wrong and they're extremely grateful.
But there was a sense of guilt throughout our entire family that we get to move
on in their family lives with this burden much like we do for the rest of their
lives.
Well,
I can tell you that,
uh,
when you said
it's a reminder of not in a good way,
I would actually dispute that with you and I promise you that it's,
it's a men that they love,
they love hearing from you and talking to you and,
and anyone,
same,
same with mark,
same with Ryan,
same with same with all of our friends at a fall.
And if you can go,
go and tell a story that they haven't heard before or tell a story that they've
heard a hundred days before,
it's,
it's worth it.
It's worth it.
At what point did you realize that you are going to heal quick enough to go back
in to another platoon?
They actually,
they told me to take a take a knee and they wanted to give me orders out of the
team three and to take a easy tour and relax.
Um,
which is the strangest thing I would ever think to hear from a bunch of seals,
seal leaders.
It was actually okay.
And then you need to heal,
need to get back in the game as quickly as possible because that's what's best
for you.
So talk them out of the fact that you're not sending me away from seal team
three.
So what did they do?
Uh,
in response to that,
they aligned me into another platoon that is heading to pick up for the
listeners.
Paycom means specific man.
That means we're going over to the Philippines to work with the uh,
the,
the Philippine seals.
And you will not be in combat.
You are doing a host nation building.
And funny enough,
when they align the platoons,
there's these little placards with your face and I'm,
and your name.
And in the master chiefs,
that's a big magnet magnet called the weegee board.
Cause that's how they stack up.
Who's going where.
And so the master chief's office,
this is a no kidding story was open and they've got the three tasks units with
each of the platoons underneath them,
the two platoons.
And all the pictures of who's in what platoon,
and I'm in this,
but two,
I'm going to pick them.
So what I do is take my magnet,
take some junior officer that's an in a scent combo tune,
going back to Iraq,
put my picture there,
put his picture in the Paycom platoon,
literally go up to the tune space and getting most of the guys name say,
Hey,
so and so you've just been a resigned to this platoon.
Go recording.
And I'm not kidding you.
That is how that happened.
And no one ever said a thing,
either one,
they didn't,
uh,
they didn't recognize that it had happened or two,
they're just like,
okay,
we're not talking about at this point.
And I screwed over a kid,
uh,
by sending him to pick on first.
But first platoon,
I don't feel all that bad about it.
Yeah.
So you knew how long it take you to heal up.
So it was about a four months of debris.
So you know,
I had some holes that were as deep as half a golf ball.
And if you don't pick the scab off,
then it'll heal.
In a concave manner.
So this little doctor,
a female doctor,
I had to go in every day and she would pick at the scab to keep the wound fresh
so that it heals out,
called her doctor pain.
But did that for about four months.
Um,
then I had to get the legs working and actually start to walk and then run.
Uh,
but overall four months,
cause remember when the team comes back from a deployment that go into a six
month individual training cycle so guys can go to sniper school.
And so I had time to heal,
but,
uh,
there's still a lot of SRAP metal in my,
in my legs.
Uh,
we formed up with a platoon,
um,
I'd put on some bad weight.
Um,
and then,
uh,
you know,
throughout that entire two,
uh,
to your trading and trading cycle.
In fact,
a guy named Derrick Benson and we both know and Derek was killed on extortion.
17 would,
uh,
cut into my legs.
The,
the trap mental that was pushing towards the skin,
he would remove it.
So I had a little jar of,
of SRAP metal,
uh,
throughout that two year period that he would even take out.
And He loved it.
He loved the medicine side.
And then you roll back back to Iraq.
Yeah.
Do you remember anything in workup and he spectacular or you're giving me that
look,
most people that I put through work of giving that look,
so Aa haven't workin for Jocko.
You,
you know,
eyes we're going to be on me.
You know,
naturally I put it on myself.
One of those,
uh,
self inflicted pressures that he's going to expect expect me to,
to perform at a higher level given the amount of combat experience I had had.
And you had by that point drastically changed how the west coast seal teams
prepare for war.
And it was,
um,
you know,
it,
it was good pressure.
I like pressure.
I like when somebody holds me accountable.
And I think echo and I were talking about this,
you have a very uncanny way of having a conversation without saying a word and
you sorta,
you know,
the eyebrows come down lower and if you just stare and,
and what I've said is like,
you would,
you would do that and look at me during the training and be like,
Hey,
here's the standard
for everyone else.
Here's your standard.
Get it done.
Good Talk.
And so you,
there were probably runs browse harder on myself than you were,
but,
um,
I do remember a mountain.
Yeah.
Military operations are from terrain specifically in Kentucky.
Um,
and that was some of the best training.
Uh,
we'd,
uh,
we'd gone through and again,
that was drastically different than the prior workup and to Romani and a for the
guys that had not seen combat,
um,
given what happened on the next deployment that that absolutely prepared us for,
uh,
for what happened.
Yeah.
I mean,
coming back,
that was so ideal for me to go back and run trading.
I mean,
there's no better job.
I could and that's,
you know,
I was a little really lucky that I had good,
good relationship with the admiral and he said,
look,
where do you want to go?
And I said,
oh I want to go run and trade out because I need to get these guys ready.
That cause when we got back,
Ramadi wasn't done yet.
It ended up finishing up pretty quickly thereafter.
But I was just thinking,
hey everyone's going to going back and doing the same thing for another.
The average counterinsurgency lasts seven years.
This started six months ago.
We got like many years' worth of fighting and these guys need to be ready for
that specific thing that I know how to do and so I need to go run that training
and that and that's what I did and I was definitely,
it's funny cause like when you're talking about like,
like I would,
there was a lot of buddy caring going on and when I was running training and the
reason is because I,
I,
I got the debrief,
you know,
like it's,
I knew it's like this is going to be,
if you get in this situation,
it's not,
it's not what you think it is.
It's going to be hell and you,
how do you prepare for it?
You prepare for it,
you do as close.
You make this as close to combat as you can possibly make it.
Then that was my goal and it was freaking hard training and I,
you know,
I had so many guys come back over the years after that when I was running
training that were like,
Hey,
you know,
I just got back from Afghanistan.
Thank you.
And the firefights,
we're literally easier than going through a block of land warfare.
They would be so stoked.
And it was awesome.
That's like the best compliments I've ever gotten in my life was having those
guys come back.
And,
and also I was just talking to,
as a matter of fact,
I was talking to the guy that told me that you are good to go the other day.
And he's,
he's like,
oh,
we would have had so many blue on blues if we didn't go through that workup.
We were so much better.
We were so prepared.
And they had,
they had a freaking hardcore,
a deployment to Afghanistan and they kicked ass and he's like,
yeah,
we were totally good to go because that training set us up.
And so that was,
uh,
that was a real honor for me to be able to get to do that.
But yeah,
I was a little bit,
I was also a little bit still,
like I,
I remember,
and I've talked about this before on the podcast,
but like I be in mount,
like it watching urban training going on and I'd see like a,
a new guy or something like standing in the middle of the street and I would
literally feel like a sickness in my stomach,
like a pit.
Like just like when I was in Ramadi,
if you'd see someone in the street,
you'd be like,
dude,
get off the street.
I would have that feeling.
And so when I'd go over and talk to them,
it would generally be like,
like pretty hostile.
Like,
Bro,
what the hell are you doing?
You're,
you're in the middle of the street.
Get out of here.
You're going to get freaking killed.
And so yeah.
Um,
it was good and it was good that we put you guys through that cause you guys
went right back into the fire,
right back into the fire on,
on that next appointment.
And you know,
leading into that for the last month,
I had my son who I named after Mikey,
so his name is Michael Anthony Cirelli.
It was Michael Anthony [inaudible].
He knows he's not named after me.
So I get to see him born less than two weeks after that.
We all end up in DC to see Mikey posthumously recognize with the metal of honor.
And then from Washington d C I fly directly to uh,
to the Middle East.
And then in direct,
I mean it literally butted up when we were deploying again.
And so we ended up back in Al Anbar province,
Iraq.
I ended up specifically in Ramadi,
which is completely different,
completely pacified.
And part of you just can't even believe it.
He's just like,
no,
it's,
wait,
just wait.
It's coming.
They're going to attack.
And No,
it's not that way.
While at the same time we were arriving in Iraq,
the solder militia backed by Iran,
Iranian special groups,
they're what we call the cuts forces there.
Their special forces had kicked off a major or a spring offensive,
and this is spring of 2008.
And so the army is getting hammered inside of a solder city.
Soldiers are dying and they request sniper support from the US Special
Operations Command specifically see just soda of uh,
AP and
that seed soda if knowing that seal team three had run that similar mission in
support of the one one ready combat brigade,
uh,
the deployment Pryor said,
hey,
can you guys run this mission?
So our commander at the time and master chief,
we're faced with a decision.
We had commitments in Al Anbar province.
You just couldn't shut down a location and send that entire unit to solder city
that,
that wasn't going to work.
So he had to make a decision of taking seals from all the particular outstations
and Al Anbar and thrown them into sort of this hodgepodge unit.
So you had seals from two different seal teams thrown together.
And uh,
we loaded up a bunch of rgs,
I think eight,
eight and hall and a 40 bus drove out to the Baghdad international airport and
set up a new unit called debt defender,
a detachment,
naval special warfare to detachment of Baghdad.
And we named it defender Saint Michael,
the archangel the defender after Mikey.
And we created this bad ass up patch that had the archangel on there and we all
knew,
um,
in some of Mikey's boys that have gone through buds,
we're in this new unit.
Good,
good friends of mine.
I that weren't in Iraq at that time.
They had deployed to,
to the Philippines.
And so,
uh,
we are located in Baghdad,
but solder cities like an hour and 15 minutes away from Baghdad international
airport.
And so,
you know,
they are screaming for us to get in.
And again,
this unit has never worked together.
Some of them have,
like these three guys came from this platoon.
They'd worked together,
but they hadn't worked with these guys in the seal teams and the,
uh,
both the conventionals and a CG soda for screaming for us to get in there.
And so we did the best we could,
rehearsals,
uh,
the planning.
We had never operated in the area,
maybe some people had,
but there was where the very senior seals.
Um,
and we get thrust into solder city primarily around this,
this rout called rout gold.
And they were trying to,
at that point,
the,
the strategy was to cordon off or enclosed solder city with these large t
barriers so that we can control the entry points into the city and hence cut off
supplies or enemy troops,
uh,
coming into the city.
And ultimately the strategy worked.
But the first night in all 40 of us go in and,
um,
again,
remember we had this like young Intel officer who had just come from first time
in Iraq,
had come from Allie and bar where you're dealing with now the remnants of a,
of a Sunni enemy.
And we're now operating in Shia territory and in Shia enemy completely two
different styles of fighting two different purposes.
Um,
one will get their Jihad on to the point where they die.
Others are not necessarily going to give their lives.
They're going to fight and then pull back and then find another day.
And,
uh,
he didn't understand really the difference.
And so the Intel wasn't exactly aligning.
Again,
we hadn't been in the area.
We go in the first night and all hell breaks loose.
I remember Chris Kyle's with us.
These are lead sniper and we're trying to get into a position and um,
I mean we had fps,
uh,
detonated on our patrol for the listeners.
An EFP is an explosive forming projectile.
Again,
if you remember these were Iranian made and what it is is a concave plate of
copper with a lot of explosive behind it.
When you detonate it,
it turns it into a molten,
a projectile Bolton ricocheting bullet.
Yes.
And this thing could cut through Bradley,
an Rg and Abrams tank come right through like a hot knife through butter.
These things were nasty and they were killing troops.
We had that detonated on us and then they own the rooftops and they had what we
were trying to do to them.
And so we are just like fish in a fish bowl and they are shooting.
Chris took one round in the helmet mount off.
Um,
and,
uh,
you know,
Seth had now taking your position as the,
and it really is the band got back together a task you to bruiser.
And so Seth is back with the Stryker company that insert in us doing his job at
deconfliction and making sure we had the support we needed.
And shortly after a week called for hot extract.
I mean,
guys,
we're getting low on ammo.
Uh,
the,
the enemy's maneuver in Rpgs p can fire,
uh,
on the rooftops,
down into us.
How we did not lose a guy.
I will never know.
And what I like to say is that Mark Ryan and Mikey were looking after us or hey,
you got this one,
we're going to give this one idea and reset.
But,
um,
we called Seth in and Lo and behold,
I do remember this about sat does as the Strykers come in.
And strikers are a,
it's like an armored version of a Humvee,
uh,
with,
wheels that can carry more trips than Humvee,
larger and,
um,
and they have some pretty good armament and weapons systems.
And the ramp lowers,
it's Seth runs off and starts firing into a building.
And of course it says down,
he's like,
let's go get on the strikers.
And uh,
the guy start loading up and the strikers are,
and getting after it to the point where they went Winchester to getting us out
of there in one of the striker operator says,
Hey,
give me your gun.
And I hand him my Sr 25 and he just starts going at it at my aunt and my last
naggy reloads and he's just getting after it.
Well,
tell you what,
um,
humbling experience,
put us back into the same position.
Like a new guy in Ramadi.
Okay.
Hey,
we've got some great experience.
We got to reset.
And we said,
hey,
give us like 36 hours.
We need you to some serious planning.
We needed to do some series of rehearsals.
We did that.
Um,
and then we inserted shortly after that.
But you know,
the funny thing,
he was the only time,
like I really felt,
um,
vulnerable.
And I remember I called my brother before we inserted that the next time and I
said,
hey,
I don't think things are going to work out here.
Um,
let my kids know alone a and make sure,
you know,
my daughter grows up to be a person of character and make sure my grandma and my
son grows up to be a man.
And me and my brother don't talk all that much.
But for me to make that call was probably a bad choice.
And for him to hear that probably put a lot more concern on his plate.
But we inserted and we got into position and the guy started and knock it out of
the park.
And then mission after mission they just kept eliminating got combatants,
sig acts started to a dive.
We had one 72 hour operation where the guys eliminated 50 fighters and within
three weeks,
uh,
I think I want to eliminate it and I don't want to hyperbole here or plus up
numbers.
I think it was like one 25 to one 50.
Within three weeks the guys eliminated and Sig gas went to almost zero.
And then there was not much to do for the rest of the deployment.
The Greeks were
significant activities as enemy attacks basically.
But what's also interesting is that at the tail end of that,
the shakes inside solder city came out and said,
hey look,
we're good.
We're here to make friends now.
We're done with this.
And what was really awesome was it solder city had been a complete nightmare for
five straight years.
I mean,
solder city was completely uncontrollable.
And then in a six week period,
give or take that the,
that those operations took place.
It was like done.
It was like they,
the,
the shakes came out and said,
Yep,
we'll,
we'll keep this under control.
We want to make peace.
And,
and that's what happened.
That was,
that was a,
that was an unbelievable set of circumstances.
Dude,
I,
you know,
the one thing that I had to pull him out,
I remember in,
in,
you know,
it showed I'd earn SAS trust because of the distance between the Baghdad
international airport and solder city.
The conventional unit that was supporting us when we go into solder was in
outside of solder city.
So he's like,
Hey,
Mike and I th I think I spent all three weeks out.
He's like,
Hey,
um,
stay there planned missions.
Uh,
if you need to do a recky of the site,
go out with the conventionals.
And so for three weeks,
like I wasn't with the boys,
they would move to me and then we would execute the mission.
But,
uh,
you know,
learning what we had about unity of effort and putting your ego aside and
building a personal capital through relationships,
we built a great relationship with the,
uh,
the 10th mountain and they gave us anything we needed.
And we,
there was a lot of lessons learned from Ramadi that we,
you know,
we took in that we actually stepped up in terms of the mission planning and
preparation with some of the assets of the Dia 10th Mountain head.
But I was going out with the conventionals by myself.
Uh,
if I needed to get to another,
a outstation or a cop,
they would have a convoy of Bradley's waiting for me.
Just from me,
and I loved it,
but Seth realized I was probably getting a little off the reservation.
At one point we conducted an admission,
uh,
we got back to that,
that larger base,
and he said,
hey,
go get your stuff.
And coming back.
And I'm like,
I actually think I barked a little with them and he's like,
go get yourself out of a bag.
That was pissed because I was loving it was criminal Kurtz in it,
loving it.
He,
you know,
he made the right call.
So yeah,
yeah,
no,
you guys did an outstanding job there.
And again,
it wasn't,
obviously,
it wasn't just you guys.
The 10th Mountain did freaking unbelievable job.
The,
some of the images that were coming back at that time of those guys putting that
t barrier up right in the middle or right at the,
what side of solder city was at the eastern side of solder city.
Then you could see those guys out there putting that barrier,
putting those berries up.
The conventional army guys was freaking awesome,
man.
What,
what,
what awesome awesome guys.
Then you come back from that deployment.
You'd think you,
maybe you had enough yet?
Not really.
You know,
on that,
uh,
in that vein,
I sat down with that commanding officer of team three at the time and uh,
you know,
I had gotten orders to an east coast team and uh,
he was doing my final fit rep and sending me off and read a pretty,
pretty good.
And he said,
Mike,
uh,
the last thing I want to leave you with is at some point it becomes about
family.
And uh,
I'm looking at them and I pause for about 10 seconds.
And I said,
Roger,
that sir,
but within the hamster wheel,
turning in my head was,
are you freaking kidding me?
I'm going to deploy as much and as often as I can because this thing is not
going to last forever.
And I'm going to,
to,
to another command w w with a bunch of warriors.
And I knew I want to get right in stride and deploy as much as possible.
But in retrospect,
towards the end I realized what he was trying to tell me.
At some point you got to pull back.
Yeah.
So it only took you another,
what,
seven years,
years,
years.
The figure that out.
So you get out to the east coast and now you're doing just more deployments.
Yeah.
Um,
first one was to,
uh,
to Afghanistan with a great group of guys,
man,
uh,
you know,
I loved,
love these guys,
a different feel to them.
Uh,
but my first mission out was a probably one of the toughest missions I've ever
been on in terms of just like terrain because we're in cone,
our province now.
How I would describe cone,
our province is man town,
uh,
take,
you know,
some of the worst areas of,
of the Colorado Rockies and then maybe multiply it by two and a,
the enemy,
I mean,
they were,
this was their territory.
They had prepared positions.
It was a dangerous area and put it into perspective a little more for a,
for the listeners,
you know,
of all the metals of honor within Afghanistan,
I think the majority,
all of them were in that cone,
our stand,
uh,
area to,
to glued Dakota Myers.
Um,
and,
uh,
on the first mission,
the eye,
he just was like a,
an eight hour hour,
um,
suck fest.
And,
uh,
actually you,
so Adam Brown was,
was killed on that operation and that was my,
uh,
sort of a baptism to fire to that new unit.
Um,
and I remember I looked at it,
good friend Jonas who's going storage and 17 and said,
April,
are all the missions like that?
He was like,
no,
that was,
that was the toughest one I've ever been on.
I'm like,
Oh God,
I just want to make sure I need to get my head right.
If little sanity,
you're like,
oh no,
what did I get myself into?
But,
um,
it,
it was good to,
to,
to work with that team,
um,
and,
and get that experience.
And then I got a lot of time with,
with the maritime side as well,
the boats.
Um,
but did a in all with them.
What was that?
Seven more deployments,
um,
with great guys and,
you know,
lost some more brothers.
Uh,
namely,
uh,
extortion 17,
which was the largest loss of life in Afghanistan.
Um,
just,
you know,
it,
it's a travesty when we lose one soldier,
marine,
sailor,
airman,
but when you
lose 31,
um,
that is just,
you know,
that that hits the military to,
to the listeners,
they may say,
well,
31 soldiers,
you guys can easily recover from that.
You can't,
it all the man hours that go into training,
those guys,
the level proficiency they had crude over years like that is like,
that is a catastrophic failure or a detriment to the military.
That is a loss of a lot of capability,
uh,
yet alone.
The pain for those 31 families,
uh,
the children,
the,
or not the orphans,
but the kids that are left behind,
the wines that are left behind and that we'll never have any solace.
Um,
other than that their loved ones were doing what they believed in for them,
defending them.
Um,
but overall,
I mean,
great seven years,
um,
and just nothing but lessons learned and leadership lessons,
uh,
in terms of being a troop commander.
And quite frankly,
you know,
my last experience,
I learned a lot,
which was not my best,
uh,
leadership experience.
Um,
you know,
you look at extreme ownership and there's ways I could have handled certain
situations better or not.
I think I reflect on my entire military career,
uh,
just on man,
I could have done that better.
That's what we all do.
Sit back and think,
man,
we could've done that better.
It's goes back to what I was saying earlier about like,
if,
you know the way than the way appears everywhere,
but when you don't know it,
you're seeing like little,
like even I remember when I was young man young and I do something that was like
partially right,
but then I do something that wasn't,
and I think of myself,
if I would've known if I would have gotten some reinforcement,
if I would've figured it out better,
you know,
like figured it out better and you just don't.
And that's one of the hardest things about,
one of the hardest things about is not just the seal teams.
It's the military.
When you complete a job,
you don't get to do it anymore.
Uh,
you,
you get done with your assistant platoon commander and you're like,
okay,
I got this figured out,
I'm ready to do it again.
They were like,
no,
now you're going to be platoon commander and then you get done with your platoon
commander.
You Go,
okay,
I got this figured out,
I'm ready to do it again.
They don't know you're going to be attached to the commander.
And then as soon as you get,
you figure something out,
you're done with that job and you can't go back and do it.
Very seldom do you get to go back and do it.
Yes.
And so we all sit around and look back and,
and,
and there's another weird thing about this whole deal,
this whole deal is that it's so hard to,
someone's got to have a real open mind to be able to teach it to people.
You know someone's gotta be,
wait,
when is someone's Gus got to have an open mind to,
like I would say when I was running trade at,
I would say like 30 or 40% of the people would be like listening and absorbing
and which is print,
which is pretty good.
It's actually pretty good,
but there was like 30% of the people that you know,
I would try and explain something to them and it just wouldn't,
they just wouldn't like you're putting the way in front of them,
but what?
They don't recognize it.
They can't,
they can't see it.
And so it's easy now that you know the way,
when you look back at your own experiences,
you go the the way appears everywhere,
but you didn't see it back.
I didn't see it back then.
I'm just looking at it going,
burn,
why didn't I one that figured that out?
It's one of those things and I think that's one of the things that that makes
what I'm doing now,
what you're doing,
what we're doing now as a team is to be able to,
to try and pass these lessons on to leaders everywhere and you know,
leaders in the military leaders and police leaders and fire leader in business,
egg,
everyone to be able to say,
look,
hey,
this is it over here.
I know this is hard to see,
but look at this and,
and it's awesome to be doing what we're doing now and say,
oh,
and have people again,
a certain percentage of people that go,
I got it,
I got it.
I can take that.
And what's interesting about our business now is when people are raising their
hand and they're asking for it,
that means their mind is open to,
they're open to it,
they want it.
Whereas with,
and this does happen occasionally when we work with companies that were getting
imposed on,
you know,
like the board of directors and saying,
Hey,
go fix this comp,
this company screwed up.
You've got to go fix them.
Most people don't have open minds.
So they're,
they're looking,
when you were talking to them,
they were looking for reasons that what you're saying is wrong.
If that's their goal is to say,
no,
that doesn't apply to me.
It doesn't apply to this market.
It doesn't.
But it's like,
no,
we actually worked with eight companies in your exact industry,
your competitors,
and they have the same problem.
This is how they fix it.
But no,
this is different for us.
Okay.
It's different for you.
Leadership is different in your specific company.
Leadership is different than it is everywhere else.
No,
that's actually not true.
Not True at all.
So it's an unfortunate,
you know,
I've been thinking about this too because you know,
I gotta,
I gotta I got a son,
you know,
I've got three daughters and a son and,
and,
and the fact of the matter is you don't see yourself as much in your daughters
as you do and your son,
right?
Your son is,
uh,
he's,
he's a boy,
a small man.
And Man,
what I wouldn't give to be able to just like put the knowledge in there,
you know,
cause you see them doing stuff and you go and you could,
this is my own flesh and blood by the way that I say,
hey,
that's not a good way to handle that.
Here's a good way to handle it.
And he looks at me like I'm an 88 right?
Like how would you ever know what it's like to deal with the school teacher?
You know what to deal with a coach,
how would you know what that's like to deal with another person?
You know what you're right.
I'm sure you have this year 15 now,
so I'm sure you've got it all figured out.
This is the one thing I leave kids with and I gotta tell you my,
my old man was probably right 95% of the time.
But did I listen though?
No,
no.
He's
your father to come up to me and be like,
Hey,
can you talk to my son?
He loves,
he wants to be a seal.
What can you leave them with?
Listened to your old man.
He may not know what the right decision is
or right path is on certain things,
but he will tell you what the wrong path.
Sometimes knowing what not to do is as valuable as knowing what to do.
You know what else I tell when?
When fathers asked me to talk to their sons,
I tell the sons,
I say,
listen,
your dad actually cares about you more than you do.
He,
he wants an outcome for you,
a good outcome for you more than you do.
I know that doesn't seem possible,
but for him to come and ask me to like talk to you means that what he wants more
than anything in the world is for you to be in a good place in the future.
That's what he wants.
He doesn't want to screw you over.
This isn't a plot to get you to fail in life.
He actually wants you to win more than anything.
So you may want to listen to them.
Yeah,
check.
So it's at this point,
you do.
You do.
So what are you at?
You did nine deployments overseas total.
Ten nine,
10,
10 deployments overseas.
And add finally,
the little voice in your head says,
you know what,
I need to a
look at something else.
Probably.
Yeah,
probably the toughest decision.
Uh,
I had to make,
I mean,
a lot of guys,
like a lot of guys thought you were a 30 year vet.
Easy.
He's good.
He's going to do 30,
probably more.
[inaudible] they usually say the same about me.
Um,
in Akron and I were talking about this age just came over me like a,
uh,
like a wave just crushed me.
It was just like,
Yup,
it's,
it,
it's like I'm,
I'm,
I'm tapping out in a sense.
At the end of the day,
you always ring the belt to the community.
They're like,
oh,
you're quitting quitter.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
I,
I'd had one last few deployment with a different group and it was awesome to
work with these guys.
And,
um,
you know,
there was a lot of things going on.
One I finally felt the,
uh,
the fatigue,
um,
and the hardest thing to do for any seals to tap out,
but it's because you know that you're no longer like the best guy to push that
unit forward.
And I also was going through a divorce at the time and,
um,
things were just,
you know,
things were out of balance.
And,
uh,
even though I wanted to take the Xo of a squadron,
um,
I knew I was not the best option for the guys.
And,
uh,
even though I could probably maintain the job,
that's not the right answer.
If I can not keep them uncomfortable and moving forward then,
then I wasn't the right guy.
And so,
you know,
we talk about brutal self assessments.
That was the most brutal self assessment cause he,
I had to admit that
all,
you know,
however good I thought I was at what we did,
what we did,
eight,
just I come to a point where things were to grading it.
So,
uh,
you know,
over overseas I called back to,
uh,
you know,
my,
my CEO at the time and I said,
I'm done.
And,
uh,
they said,
okay,
we understand that that's a mature decision.
Uh,
you know,
he wanted me to stay.
He's like,
I want you to be my ex.
Oh Man.
He actually referred or referred me to the,
uh,
the captain from the,
the raid and the Philippines.
The ranger,
the one that did all the planning.
I'm,
I'm forgetting the name now,
but he used to call him that
and he said,
I understand what he want to do.
It's like,
do you want to go to,
uh,
Memphis in like working on a detail shop?
I said,
no.
Hey,
get me orders to,
to Texas.
My ex is probably moving back to Texas.
That's where she's from.
And I want to be close to my kids.
I need to repair that relationship.
Um,
in,
you've talked about it,
you know,
families come second,
the bottom line when you were at war,
you have so many responsibilities on Ya.
One,
bring your guys home that the families come second.
And so that,
that was my new priority.
And so,
you know,
testament to the seal community,
they,
they made things happen.
They realigned things and they got me a bill it at the University of Texas naval
ROTC.
Um,
we're one,
uh,
Admiral William McRaven was sitting as the,
the ut chancellor.
Boom.
Yeah.
And then so,
so did you go to school?
So you got down there and was it to get your degree?
It,
no,
it was to be an ROTC instructor.
Okay.
And,
um,
they'd also prep the battlefield,
say,
Hey,
the guy wants to get a,
a,
a master's degree,
but that was the collateral just to get your degree.
And so literally I had one late week to apply for the,
uh,
the full time MBA program at ut.
Uh,
took the a instead of the g mat,
I took the,
uh,
the Ac new and I'm trying to think of the ECG act,
um,
and um,
or GRE did you already thank you.
And the scores were,
we're not so hot.
Uh,
and I've made some phone calls and I got in and um,
you know,
that was a humbling experience as well to start,
we,
we in a sense,
I don't want to say mastered,
but we become very good at become being seals at the art of war,
which takes years and years to hone.
And even then you're never as good as you think you are,
but you've put it and put time in,
you've built some level of mastery and then to step into accounting and finance
with a bunch of 27 year olds in here,
the 39 year olds in the a course and you'd have this puzzled look on your face
cause one you've been blown up a couple of times and actually I went to some
training where they're like,
hey,
you've suffered cognitive degregation to the amount of 50%.
Why
make that excel spreadsheet move slower than then?
So I was grabbing these younger kids like,
Hey,
show me how to do that man.
I'm no clue what you guys are talking about.
And it's like,
okay.
And they all love me.
They,
they knew there was something different about me.
And I remember it came time for the,
the first task and one of the younger kids,
he was actually one of the owners in the class who is 26.
He's like,
sir,
when's the last time you took a test?
I'm like 14 years ago,
so shut up.
But uh,
so it was a,
it was hard stepping back into an academic environment and people are like,
well,
did you been to combat this is going to be easy for you.
Hey,
it's like a different type of stress brother.
And like,
you know,
one,
we all drive ourselves to do well and the first few test and not come back
favorable in Mike's is a call him.
And so I buckled down and I'm actually did quite well.
Um,
but after the first semester,
the basics of business,
it gave me a good grounding and I'm like,
Hey,
I think I can do something.
I actually think I can do something good.
A payback to the community.
They hooked me up to be here where there's no military base.
Um,
I'm supposed to go back to the community and I know there's,
there's a problem with debts getting out,
especially seals.
They're not getting jobs commensurate with their abilities and companies should
be swallowing these guys up.
Leaders.
I mean,
the one thing you can't deny is the military is the preeminent leadership
training platform in the nation.
No debating it.
And I'm not saying that the world is,
might be the world.
I'm not saying there's not great leaders out there that have not been in the
military.
Actually there,
there,
there are more than,
than people would like to think.
There's a lot of great leaders and never had an military training,
but as a whole,
and as you said about the marine corps,
they tend to turn out this,
this,
this standard product,
which is a cut above.
And the same thing with the military general.
And so,
uh,
you know,
dog Nano McRaven and a great guy named who was as vice chancellor,
Major General Tony Cucolo and this guy has become a real big mentor to me.
Um,
love them.
We talked about this and basically walked myself into a project,
uh,
which we got approved by the McCombs business school 20 vets.
Uh,
we,
we did a analysis into the systemic challenges facing veterans when they get out
in terms of employment.
And it was a 60 page paper,
which was met with quite a better reception.
And then again,
walking myself into more work.
Everyone's like,
hey dude,
we think you guys have a business concept of this,
uh,
out of this paper.
You need to take it one step further.
We'll,
we'll prove another project the next semester.
And hence something called the vetted was formed.
And to give a quick brief on vetted,
so vetted,
uh,
having done all the gap analysis of current programs out there and all the
research we did,
uh,
we feel we found a solution and actually Huffington post hailed vetted as
revolutionizing the way that veterans exit the military.
So 80 is bar none,
the most comprehensive program out there and it's still building itself up.
So a partnership between Wharton University of Texas mccomb's MBA program and
the Texas a and M Mays business program.
Um,
and be a program.
We developed something called the veteran accelerated management program.
It's optional.
Five months of online education through the Wharton business foundations course,
uh,
as a preparatory to a two month in house,
um,
uh,
residence program that basically gives them a very strong business acumen over
the know within that two months,
over the course of those seven months,
um,
they receive more career development,
which is almost as important as acquiring the business skills than an MBA
student gets into years.
And that's how to interview how you're,
you know,
uh,
refine your resume,
optimize your resume and linkedin a mock interviews.
Um,
but they,
they hit all the basic verticals of business,
even entrepreneurs that they have a business idea.
They came in,
they have a executable business plan on the back end.
And for those that want to go into industry,
actually every Thursday,
Friday,
they're working on a industry capstone embedded in a company.
So during that eight weeks,
every Thursday,
Friday working the project inside a company,
which means industry experience that can go on their resume and then two
organizations offer their placement services free charge.
At the end.
Okay.
Actual on front,
Overwatch and Bradley Morris ink,
which the two hat could be strategic partners,
which I'm sure we'll get into,
but I'm of the first pilot program at the University of Texas.
Mckell homes of the 25 veterans all are placed except for one.
Yeah.
So that,
so you just kind of start talking about,
the next thing obviously we need to talk about is,
you know,
at some point while you were doing this,
and here Lafe and I were with echelon front and we work with companies all the
time.
And every company we work with,
guess what they need.
They need people,
they need good people.
They need,
they need leaders.
That's what they need.
And you know,
as you and I discussed this and talked about it,
and I don't know if,
I don't know who made the connection mentally.
Uh,
I think it was you who made the connection mentally.
You're like,
oh wait,
you,
you need people and we're making people,
let's figure that out.
And that's sort of where we got into this idea of echelon front,
Overwatch.
Okay.
We did,
it was,
it was combining chocolate peanut butter,
Reese's pieces.
It was magical.
It was hatching moment.
Sorry.
Wait.
Um,
so you know,
there was a lot of lessons learned from Betty [inaudible] and you know,
when I started that there was a lot of uh,
mentors of mine,
Mine,
very successful business matters that are like,
dude,
you need to capitalize this thing.
And at the time I couldn't see it.
Like my ultra ultra wisdom sort of drove like,
no,
it needs to be nonprofit where you're not going to charge people for this.
And now I recognize that in a capitalistic market you can do more good on the
for profit side and you came to nonprofit side,
we live in a free society,
free enterprise.
And I remember sitting down in,
in Austin,
you guys,
I'm like,
Hey,
I remember you telling me that every company you talk to is like,
we're going to get like five of you.
And that just wasn't your game at the time.
Yeah.
But at the end of the day,
you know,
talent is all about leadership.
Becoming a talent magnet or having a talent mindset within your organization is
about leadership.
And so,
you know,
knowing our communities,
the special operations community in combat aviators,
Dave Burke,
you are our resident fighter pilot,
the bad ass.
Good deal Dave.
We,
we knew we could start something.
And so we created echelon front,
Overwatch,
what we call e f Overwatch,
Overwatch being the term that the mission,
we ran it in Ramadi and I think like it has a little appeal in the sense that
now we're over watching our brothers green berets,
Navy Seals,
air force,
PJ's CCTS,
Marsac guys getting out and the direct support com,
uh,
personnel,
um,
we're over watching them and help them with their transition.
We're over watching the companies that are in a war for talent.
And that's the thing that people don't understand.
Even the seals are always hunting for the best talent.
Somebody asked me,
you know,
funny enough with the most important job in the seal teams is,
and they,
they thought it was going to say a troop commander on the front lines of that.
That is important.
At the end of the day,
that's what we do.
But I said,
no,
it's actually been about butts and trucker.
That is like being a hiring manager.
You are the filter of the talent coming through,
which ultimately will end up in that troop commander in that that uh,
troop chiefs,
uh,
hands and there has to be a standard.
We need to put some of our best guys at Bud's to make sure that only the best
are passing through.
We'll do the same thing applies to business.
You are constantly in this war for talent
and we couldn't think of a better talent pool than combat aviators,
Cobra pilots,
fighter pilots.
Again,
all this special operations guys and the direct support personnel that come out
of Socom that have the soft skills,
the leadership skills that you want,
they may lack the hard skills.
You look at their resume and it may not scream right fit.
But once you get these guys in the interview and you see that one,
they,
their leaders that they're humble,
that they're willing to roll their sleeves up and get after it and actually
listen and learn.
That is the perfect employee.
If you can get more of these guys into your business,
I guarantee you you will create your own army that will dominate your
battlefield in whatever industry that you're in.
It's,
it's awesome because people,
every,
every single time I go up to Auckland company,
they'll,
they'll say,
man,
it seems like you just,
it seems like you know,
hey did you do a bunch of research to figure out did you have you been working
with us?
And we didn't know about it.
And I'd be like,
no.
Well how do you know what problems we have?
It's like,
oh cause you're a company cause you're a group of individuals or group of human
beings are trying to make something happen.
And guess what?
There's dynamics there that happened with all different organizations that to
get together and guess what?
If you take these leaders because they're amazed that I can understand that
their business,
it's like,
no,
I don't understand your business.
I understand leadership.
That's what,
that's what echelon front.
We understand leadership so we can go in and look at what's going on and say,
Oh,
you've got to have a leadership problem here and here's how we fix it.
And so to take that and say,
you know what,
we can actually give you people that understand leadership and they can help you
solve these problems.
That is like you said,
a Reese's peanut butter cup,
peanut butter and chocolate.
That's what it is.
So it's been on.
Speaking of bringing on talent,
like when this whole thing was going down,
I'm like,
oh,
how far we get a little Mike Cirelli I'd echelon front because guess what?
That's what we did.
Bring,
bring the band back together.
And you know,
that's why that's just been,
it's been awesome.
And if anyone that's coming to the monster,
um,
you know,
Mike's Mike's putting,
putting on a,
a great,
uh,
talk about leadership inside the monster freaking everyone loved it.
Uh,
I myself included and yeah,
going out,
working with companies again now we just have someone else on the team that can
get out there that understands leadership,
that sees solutions we're bringing,
we've been bringing you out on a bunch of stuff now.
So you see other companies and you see you're starting to take even what you
learned in school.
Put that on top of the practical applications that we see now.
You know the way,
so you see it everywhere you look.
So that's a,
that's a,
that's another benefit.
So that's where you're at now talking about getting out.
I mean,
you talk about what gets you out of the bed in the morning and every company,
he was like,
do you love what you do?
I'm like,
the fact that Jocko Leif,
myself,
JP,
Dave Flynn on a phone call talking about leadership,
I'm like,
there's nothing against the side of the bed.
More than that.
Like we actually like,
we love to solve these problems because we've seen them before.
And you know,
people,
people often say,
well how did the seals like synonymous with business?
I'm like,
you just said it.
You are a unit,
you're a company,
you're dealing with people and deal with the same issues and it has been great.
I mean,
how long have I been on now?
Three months.
Yeah.
Something like that.
Just love it.
And you know,
my fiance sees a different person because for the listeners I took a high level
job in higher education,
executive director of veteran services for the Texas a and m system.
And it just,
you know,
even though the work was rewarding,
it just wasn't the same as being part of national on front end.
Like Jordan has seen.
She's like,
you're,
you're actually like,
how did it get out of bed in the morning?
Now I'm like,
yeah,
I'm with the boys.
Yeah,
that makes a big difference.
And like you said,
you can't even shut us up.
Like we will have a,
like a,
we got this thing called the tank where we'll get together and talk about like a
leader,
like a for working with three companies and there'll be leadership issues at
each one of the companies.
And so we'll talk about the leadership issue and then how that problem should be
approached.
And these calls that are scheduled for an hour,
we'll end up on the phone for,
you know,
two and a half hours or we'll end up in the,
in the tank for three hours sitting there going by.
And because we're learning from it,
we're also learning how we can apply what we're talking about.
It's just,
it's just,
it's just an awesome,
it's awesome to be part of the organization and,
and like you said,
to be with people that
are just into it,
into it.
And you know,
the funny thing is having gotten my MBA,
um,
the one thing that is not addressed in any MBA program is leadership and they
know it.
And right now you're seeing a lot of MBA programs set up,
uh,
or stand up,
centers of leadership within their,
their,
their MBA programs.
And,
um,
you know,
I've had some great discussions.
I mean,
great professors there.
And so,
I mean,
strong leaders because they were private sector leaders before they came back
and spoke.
But I mean,
you can,
and they turn out highly successful business practitioners,
but at the end of the day,
like it's not a a recipe for,
for leadership training whatsoever.
Yeah,
no,
that's,
it's,
it's been awesome.
That's,
that's why the business has gone so great because there's no one that's offered
what we're doing.
There's,
there's,
there's people say,
well,
who's your competition?
I'm like,
we don't want,
we don't,
I don't mean this in a negative way,
but because I'm sure there's companies out there that are trying to do
something,
but there's no one that's saying,
hey,
this is,
this is what you do,
this is how you lead this.
This is the way this will apply to your business.
These are the principles that you can use and you can make happen.
So yeah,
that's been,
we've been pretty lucky in the fact that we,
we saw the correlations between these two things and saw him pretty clearly.
So it's been good.
And I gotta say,
so the muster in dcs who was zero five was my first muster.
And naturally any,
these guys know me,
I'm,
I'm filled with hate.
Cause you sort of what drives me.
One of my nicknames was grumpy.
Um,
but you know,
I was definitely on board because it's you guys,
you guys are my brothers.
I'm like,
yeah dude,
I want it in a,
in a uh,
love discussing leadership.
But naturally,
you know,
I always have a,
you,
you hold back a little.
I'm like,
okay,
let me see what this monster is about.
And um,
the fact that you guys are changing lives and people are coming up to me off of
one speech and I'm just like,
dude,
what is going on?
Like I gave one speech and like,
people were like,
dude,
that actually your perspective has already changed my life.
I'm like,
no,
I'm glad to hear that out.
I didn't realize the,
the impact that it has.
No,
it's,
it's an awesome thing to be a part of.
And when I say a thing to be a part of,
it's awesome to be at the muster with the people that are at the monster.
Not just like,
oh,
we're a part of it and you're not know.
It's like everyone that's there is a part of it and everyone that there is there
is contributing to the knowledge that that's being distributed and increased.
So yeah,
it's uh,
it's awesome.
Yes,
it's a good time.
It is.
And that's where you're at now.
It was probably a pretty good place to be.
I probably,
we're,
we're touching three hours almost right now or two and a half or something like
that.
Probably a good place to call it.
And I'm sure we'll do this multiple times again in the future.
Of course.
Obviously.
Thanks for coming on.
Thanks for your service in the Marine Corps,
in the teams and now Adeline echelon front at Echelon Front,
Overwatch.
Clearly Mike is out here doing his job.
He's done his job and now maybe we could get echo to do his job and talk about
how we can all do our job better in some way somehow.
Sure.
Could you help us with that one?
Yeah,
sure.
Be Happy too.
Cool.
We're on the path,
right?
Yeah.
I'm on the path.
You're on the path.
Alright.
Jocko Jocko is the path we owe them.
Let's not get crazy.
The very least.
You're all up on the path.
The trying to be on the path.
That's where I'm at.
I need to get crazy.
All right,
so that being said,
we're all trying to stay on the path the best we can.
So here,
here are the ways to do this some ways.
Some ways.
Yeah.
Just some suggestion here.
Like you're the authority on the path.
You're to sound like the ideas and good ideas.
Yeah.
Proven,
proven.
Most of these are all proven through experience,
true,
et Cetera.
You know,
affirmative origin.
Origin.
Main dot comes called origin.
Our company origin,
American made stuff.
Jeez.
Rash Guard for Jujitsu.
Other stuff as well.
Apparel.
Why does it pair will get like a,
like a tone,
you know?
Because you know,
cause you know how you get,
you know,
but the whole like apparel,
like you're not a fashion person.
Well then again,
apparel and fashion is different.
Okay.
Yeah.
Because apparel is what you wear as a human and fashion is something else that
you were trying to look a certain way or give a certain flavor to your vibe,
which I'm not a fan of.
You're not a fan of flavor to your vibe.
Your goal.
I went to,
when I went to college,
there was this woman who was a Buddhist monk.
Sure.
And as I was learning about Buddhists,
they,
one of the things that they said was like,
you're not supposed to stand out.
Like just just don't stand out.
Just just fit in.
Right.
That's part of the program.
Yeah.
Technically it's not fit in.
It's just don't stand out like maybe one of those two.
And if you're a practicing Buddhist,
you can come on and brief,
brief me on this.
I'm sure I need help.
This is how I read it.
Okay.
Don't you know,
just don't stand out.
You're just trying to be,
it's,
it's like an ego thing,
right?
It's like,
don't look at me.
Don't look at me because I'm just,
I just wear a black tee shirt and a pair of jeans.
Don't look at me.
I'm just a normal dude over here.
Nothing special.
I'm not wearing billing as they call it.
Nope.
So,
but there was a,
there was a person there that was a Buddhist monk
and the Buddhist monk war,
all the Buddhist garb,
like the robe and the stuff,
which I don't care.
Hey,
when I was in Thailand,
it's awesome.
It's actually awesome seeing the monks
walk around and they come and gather rice for me in the morning.
And it's,
it's,
it's like awesome.
It's seems to be the most,
uh,
really chill and religion out there.
Right?
And so I'm down with the Buddhists,
but if you're not in Thailand with Bu,
other Buddhist monks where it's normal,
well then you what,
guess what happens when you put on the robe?
He's damn stand out and you're saying,
look at me and that's what I gathered from.
And I was like,
Hey,
no,
look at me.
Right.
In fact,
my goal is like,
don't look at me.
That's the goal.
Look at me.
Yeah.
Oh,
so,
okay.
So I think,
and not to go too far deep into this whole,
we were just talking about where we're here.
Hey,
you brought it up.
True.
It's less about,
because when the Buddhist puts on his garb,
regardless of where he or she is,
when they put in the guard,
that's just how,
that's just the garb kind of thing.
He's there.
That's not regardless of where we're hearing where he or she is,
because check it out.
If you're in Thailand and you put on the normal monk outfit,
sure you look normal.
Yes.
If you're in a university where everyone's dressed in western clothing,
shorts,
t shirts,
and you put on the garb,
then guess what?
You're don't look normal.
Right?
If you stand out and it almost says,
look at me because the true in my opinion,
like uh,
like if you really wanted to,
to attain that level of Ego,
less enlightenment,
enlightenment,
then you just be dressing like the normal people dress.
Nothing more,
nothing less just right down the middle.
Right.
But don't look at me,
I'm just over here doing what I'm doing.
But I think,
and I don't know,
but I think it's possible that it's less about the result of them standing out
and more about the effort or lack of effort or no effort made to stand up
because that's what it is.
Buddhists is like,
you can't be attached to like your personal,
it's like you what I'm saying,
so if you,
if you're used to putting on this the garb every day.
That's just how I put this on you guys.
I can stand out or not stand out.
I'm,
I'm focused on,
I'm just talking about your way.
Yeah,
it's,
it has to be an income.
Well that's cool.
I'll change my attitude towards the monk that I went to college with.
That's why.
That's why he's the the,
what do you call it,
the leader he knew cause because he just opened my men anyway.
How can origin main help us stay on them?
That's why if you order something from origin Maine,
you could order something that is neon green that Pete Robert's designed.
Those fats are have neon core.
You could order something that's just black or black and gray,
which is very low pro low profile profile.
The joggers or low profiles looking as far as the colors and whatnot,
but they're joggers.
It's,
it's Kinda hip.
That's the thing right now,
joggers,
we've got a few of them most comfortable joggers in the world,
by the way.
Proven,
proven by experts expert.
Anyway,
how can I keep you us on the path?
Okay.
You did.
You did too.
You want to stick with Jujitsu?
You need a new geek.
Boom.
Best gay men in America,
by the way.
So you,
same thing.
This is another question comes up all the time is should I wear the white guy
the black year,
the Blue Guy?
In my Buddhist mind,
it was always,
look,
the white gay is just the plain g.
That's it.
You're just aware of the plain white t.
That's the way it is.
I always only wore the white gay.
Guess what I got now like a Hyena Blackie.
Guess what?
It doesn't matter anymore because everybody wears all kinds of different colored
geese while they were white,
blue or black,
right.
There's no,
it no longer is a thing to where it used to be like if you were a black gay,
you're like,
hey look,
everyone look at me right now.
Don't give it cares what color.
Cause there's a lot of those different colors and circulation.
So whereas a year ago,
I'm saying only a year ago I would've been like,
hey listen,
you need to just stick with the white gay.
That's just how right now the mind has been opened.
If you want to get a black key,
if that's the one that is is you know,
what's your into get a black one or the blue one or the blue one.
The green or the not bright neon green and neon green.
Just for clarification purposes and young green was one of the colors that are
in the spats,
which are compression pants for stuff.
So anyway,
anyway,
stay on the path,
get a new g,
continue or start Jujitsu.
Boom Path.
That's right on the path right in the middle of the path too.
By the way.
It's not,
you're not veering off.
And did you do to as part of the path also,
Joe,
when I say joggers,
sure,
yes,
they're comfortable.
I get it.
Come from,
there's no growth in the comfort zone,
whatever.
But you're pulling,
you're jogging,
getting accurate,
running,
doing these things.
You want to put on sweatpants,
right,
so to speak.
And you put on some comfortable made in America origin joggers,
bright.
You're still on the path.
Big Time.
Huge time actually.
Fair enough.
There you go.
Boom.
So there is growth in the comfort zone in a certain small,
exceptional compared to talk any more about clothing?
I will be like older we him,
he's outside of his comfort zone.
I'll be exiting the fashion area.
Have to be like,
okay wait.
If we talk about clothes,
see even by me saying like wear this,
don't wear that.
That's getting in the zone and I shouldn't be in,
which is,
I'm not going to go there.
I'm done talking about supplements.
I agree.
Cool.
Supplements.
Okay,
so Mike,
Remember supplements right when you're young,
take them off.
He's going to throw on the muscle.
[inaudible] right.
See Rescue.
I'm glad Mike's here.
We can talk about this stuff and get even more.
So for me to give me the community,
the what?
The protein faster
in every single way.
Lift more weights to be more big,
bigger,
less working out
and then smaller tee shirts.
You understand?
So,
but we,
and we never thought about,
hey,
what about joint supplements?
You know,
like,
you know when you're young you're like,
Eh,
I'll cool maybe for like older folks or something like this and I get it,
but not man,
give me the protein powder.
Give me the BCA is right.
You got it.
So current,
you know,
things are always evolving.
New Information,
better information,
accurate information.
Joint supplements are more important than protein powder supplements.
I would agree.
I would agree because look,
if your joints aren't working well in lifting heavy,
you don't need protein supplements because you can't lift the weights to get to
need the recovery for the protein and for growth and gains seems sane.
That is a valid point.
Before you know it,
you end up you're 40 and you can barely get out of your car after driving for
one hour.
Yeah,
and here's the thing that that is funny but not funny bro.
No,
it's real.
And which brings me to my other,
my other point,
which actually all joking aside is a big deal.
This is the biggest deal that I've actually found.
When you,
when you get more healthy joints,
your everyday activity is like way different almost till the point where you
didn't realize that you had jammed up joints.
I'm saying you're like Dang,
all this freedom was waiting for me on the other side of healthy joints decision
making.
Anyway,
point is Jocko some supplements that was joints was a long point.
Well,
Mike's here.
I figured we'd talk about it.
He's got to educate.
Yeah.
And and get educated as well.
Anyway,
joint warfare,
Krill or Super Krill oil.
These are things that go directly to joints.
Other benefits by the way,
we can talk about if you want Twitter,
I have my knees hurt.
How does joint warfare no,
which need to go to.
Yeah.
Here's how I know.
So yeah,
I have the answer to that.
That joint joint warfare knows that it goes to both knees.
Oh,
okay.
So it's like,
hey,
cover and move.
It's going to cover this.
Like,
Hey,
we got a bunch of guys,
right?
We've got a bunch of guys and they're all like,
they've been working on to say,
have some issues to say like,
no,
it knows.
Yeah.
You just tell it before you eat it,
before you take a hit.
The drone warfare say he left me.
Well,
you'd think it feels like that,
but this is what it really is.
The joint warfare doesn't know that he's no.
So it's like,
hey look,
we're all working out.
We're all doing,
you know,
various,
uh,
we're,
we're moving,
we're cleaning the guy.
That's what we're doing.
Or mowing the lawn,
moving our bodies through spirit.
Anyway,
we're doing yard work,
right.
Me,
Mike,
Jocko,
some other folks that we know right after while it's hot outside.
And then boom,
one of our,
my wife comes outside with the big bucket of ice with waters in it,
right?
Jockos a little bit bigger.
He may have worked a little bit harder than us.
He's gonna.
He might,
he might need some more water.
Mike worked a little bit,
he might need a certain amount of water,
but we all need varying amounts of water.
Sometimes the least water
is,
I've been in the shade,
maybe not working that much.
I may need a half bottle water.
You are assessing?
Yeah.
So my wife is the joint warfare with all the Omega threes and all the,
all the stuff.
Oh the nutrients.
You guys are the neat Jockos the bad knee.
Obviously I'm the good knee.
I need less of that stuff.
So we are the knees choose water,
how much water we need to say.
And this is what's cool about this is this is awesome.
This is all scientifically proven.
It 100% that the me will draw in the joint warfare.
Doesn't know that.
Nino's check Dr Reco.
That's literally how it works.
But yeah,
very important supplement.
You'll know.
Just take it,
you'll know and uh,
yeah.
Discipline.
You can take that.
You might've seen the video that Echo Charles made about discipline that I was
taking three scoops of discipline in that it put me into a,
let's just call it the zone,
his own Jujitsu.
Excellent.
The zone of Jujitsu excellence.
And you spliced up that video,
you splice it up.
I got to say thank you.
You splice it up to make me look pretty good.
I was all grinding on beam and I was all had Andy's arm and I was like,
Dang,
I look good.
I think it was just so everyone knows.
Yeah,
the rules don't always look like that.
We got some good little clips and you only hear something actually really funny
about that.
That's funny you bring that up.
Okay,
so all that foot,
remember when I came in,
just filmed whatever.
Right.
And you're willing with Dean for a lot of that time and you know when you wrote
with Dean,
it's not,
you're not just dominated.
Dean is good.
So he was kind of getting you for a little bit.
So dean error,
like literally that night he's texting me,
hey,
send me that footage.
Hey,
send me the photo.
I want to see the footage,
I want to see the footage holders,
you know,
this and that.
And I was like,
ah,
you know,
I don't know.
You know,
I'm kind of,
and he said,
hey,
I won't put something in that.
Just send me the footage.
And I was like,
okay,
didn't send it to them.
I forgot I wanted to.
But then I was like,
shoot,
should I send them this footage?
You know what?
Like what if people posted in the internet or whatever's ma'am,
that's what I'm thinking.
But I'm like,
okay,
here's the thing.
Andy said something like that,
like you were filming and Andy's all,
oh,
hey,
do you want to role even though he's here for,
and I was like,
dude,
I don't care.
Oh,
oh,
Jujitsu doesn't work on John.
He's not going to tap out.
No,
no,
actually it works on Jocko and Junko Tepsco was a freaking job.
Gets caught.
Nick damn arm lock.
So Dean wants this,
this footage.
So I'd go kind of look through the footage and there's one of him,
he takes you down and it's like funny
while he's sitting down by the way.
And then he like mounts you and he's like grinding his elbow torture.
Let me not put that part in it.
So I made you look good and what sucks is like I was doing good cause I was kind
of getting after it.
That's what part of it.
Yeah,
exactly.
Maybe look good.
So everyone,
I thank you dean Lester does not thinking.
Sorry Dude.
A also,
you know you talked about protein not being important and I actually think
you're wrong.
Well tech,
you need protein and you might as well get your protein from the what's commonly
known as the only real source of protein.
That's good.
Which is milk.
Yes.
Do you know what mark is?
I've seen it.
Yeah.
He heard here or you haven't tried it yet?
I've not tried it all,
man.
Sorry.
Dan will give you some local media.
We get spoon up here.
Yeah,
yeah.
You're,
you're,
you don't even know what you're missing a Barbara.
So yeah,
you get milk,
peanut butter,
mark will be out peanut butter,
chocolate milk will be out,
we'll call it,
we'll call it very soon.
Within a week I'm going to call it.
And then a week cause he good butter had it and it's,
yeah,
see which kind of goes to,
you'd think it's counterintuitive to his whole thing.
You know,
it was like,
hey,
let's make something that's like,
you know,
healthy,
good protein,
clean all this stuff.
But you don't want what it has to taste delicious.
And you see what I'm saying?
It kind of goes against his whole hardcore toughness thing,
right?
Just like the discipline you made.
Sure it tasted good.
So what I'm saying and that kind of funny.
It's funny how you think it's funny anyway.
Yeah.
Good,
good one replaced her dessert with milk and boom,
no sugar protein.
It's weird.
There's a substance on earth that you can replace your steak and your dessert
with one item.
And I'm not necessarily,
I'm not saying you got to do that,
but sometimes he can.
You know,
cooking a steak is a pain.
Sometimes it takes eight minutes.
You know we don't have any minutes.
Sometimes.
Boom it makes up the milk.
You're good.
Come to the immersion camp.
We'll have more with the immersion camp in Maine.
August 26 through September 2nd do you did see immersion camp?
Yeah.
Either way to immersion camp.
Not Italian immersion camp cause we won't be spoken to speaking Italian there or
any other languages.
Most likely.
Maybe a couple of Portuguese maybe some espanol.
Sure.
Yeah.
Any other,
anyone else that wants to come and speak other languages?
All this stuff that echo just talked about.
Origin main.com you can get it there.
Yup.
It's true.
Also good way to support yourself and this podcast if you want is the fact or
knowing that Daca was a store and it's called Jocko store.
Okay.
How do you support yourself with Jocko store?
If you want to represent,
if you're on the path you want to represent,
you can get a shirt says Dick.
Discipline equals freedom to now new designs on there.
If you care about that sweater you still offering the old one?
Yes.
That's an interesting decision.
Why?
I Dunno cause they're different.
They're slightly different.
Yeah,
they're just,
you know,
hey,
okay,
so I have discipline equals freedom shorts.
I have the green one,
the,
you know,
the regular hell,
what do you call the head?
They're gray.
Right?
And what's the other one?
Like a charcoal.
All same design.
So I'm like,
Hey,
you know,
if you care about this kind of thing,
hey,
I'm going to go,
I don't know,
wherever the post office I've got at the post office,
like,
hey,
that's a cool shirt.
You don't your charcoal,
just bleeding classroom.
Cool.
I go to the post office in the next day.
I'm wearing the Heather one there that he's like,
Bro,
like what up?
You just like that same design so much.
You get it in all colors.
I said,
but it's,
I'm still left with a thought like,
man,
maybe I should get a different design,
but I like discipline equals freedom.
See what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Okay.
I get to,
I guess the new designs,
I'll come back to the post office.
The guy's like,
hey,
I like this with clinicals from too.
That's dope.
But I am still,
he still has the sense like,
okay,
he has more than just that one.
Do Name.
See what I'm saying?
See what I'm saying though,
right?
I do.
Yeah.
I mean,
I know I'm kind of overstating it,
but it's still,
it's a thing.
It's not nothing.
Okay.
So on Daca story,
you can get rash cards,
tee shirts,
trucker hats.
You can get other hats,
hoodies,
hoodies.
You can get legit hoodies and,
and Hawaiian hoodies.
Twain hoodies,
if you know that Hawaiian hoodies means,
which we don't cause Jocko made that up.
It's just a lightweight hoodie.
It could be called southern California hoodie too.
Yeah.
Good shirt.
Good.
Sometimes it gets to be 38 degrees in southern California.
The Hawaiian Hoodie ain't gonna cut it.
Yeah,
I think you're going the less lightweight they look nice.
Yeah.
And anyway,
if you want to represent [inaudible] dot com he likes something,
get something.
Oh to support.
Also subscribe to the podcast.
If you haven't,
you can subscribe to it.
Itunes,
Google,
play,
stitcher.
If you leave reviews,
I read them.
Sometimes they make me laugh.
Yes,
that is good.
Yes.
Because they can be rough,
but then you read it a good review that's makes you laugh.
That's positive.
So make that happen.
Also Youtube,
by the way,
if you'd like the video video version of this podcast and a warrior can podcast.
If you haven't been listening to the warrior kid podcast,
check it out.
Sure.
It's for kids.
Ask Uncle Jake questions.
There's some good questions in there.
If you've got kids,
definitely check it out.
Youtube,
you can see echoes legit supposedly legit videos.
Oh yeah,
the excerpts.
Yeah.
Cool.
But also the ones you do your little fancy stuff.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
Uh,
again,
you're super sensitive about video bacon.
Everyone should know that.
No.
Okay,
cool.
Anyway,
um,
yeah,
so when you made it,
you made the monster video.
Yup.
And someone,
this is an interesting point.
Someone put somewhat,
I posted it to my Facebook,
I post,
I post it there and there isn't,
you know,
people commenting and then someone wrote no credit to echo.
That's it.
Echo just did,
he's doing his job and he's proud of it.
Yeah,
that's it.
It doesn't want that kind of credit credit.
Um,
I actually,
I think echo made the video.
You did your job,
you did what you're supposed to do.
Good.
Congratulations.
Well,
I think technically two in,
I mean in the spirit of just accuracy,
I think most people kind of know that I made the video.
Yeah.
Cause I just make the video.
That's like the routine,
right?
That's what it seems like anyway.
Anyway.
Sure.
Alright.
Yeah,
we're keyed.
Podcast is dope.
That's on youtube as well,
by the way.
Also,
if you want to vary up your workout,
which I think is important thing,
but you know,
hey,
people are people so,
and people are different,
but if you want to vary up your workout,
try some new stuff going on it.com/jocko you get some new gear,
gear in all capacities,
by the way.
All the way down to socks.
Uh,
we have the club.
It's a club heavy club.
Huh?
I'm going to have to check this out.
Yeah.
None of the club that you picked up,
you were like,
Hey,
are you going to do some just the leases for juggling?
And you're like,
oh no,
that's not for juggling.
You'll kill somebody in probably yourself.
But he'd see that backs up the point that I said before about those.
Those are like,
oh yeah,
you don't like cool.
It's a club.
It looks like one of those clubs that they juggle all the little pins or
whatever guy.
Yeah.
And you pick it up.
You're like,
Bro,
I can't juggle that.
That's like something you work out with and here's the thing.
Yeah,
there's full workouts with that club and there's varying weights or whatever.
Anyway,
you go to the website,
you can see,
um,
you know what workouts to do.
A lot of good info on there.
You know,
switch up your workout man.
Itunes,
Google play,
MP three.
You can get a psychological warfare.
It's an album and yes,
it has tracks and it's just me telling echo and you if you're listening not to
be weak at that moment in time.
Yeah,
no,
no.
It helps.
It helps you not be,
we were working on the second album.
Well,
I should say I'm compiling the thoughts for the second album,
which would seems like we've determined the working title at this point is all
of your excuses are lies.
Yeah.
Because that one seems to be a hit home with me,
with everyone.
All Jocko white tea.
You can get it on Amazon,
in Canada and in America.
You can get dry tea,
little tea bags that you brew or you can get the can,
which we are going to put all the big,
yeah.
Unhealthy energy drinks.
We're gonna put 'em out of business.
Yeah.
Yup.
That's the,
that's the prediction.
Sure.
Because why would you not drink Jocko white tea?
Why would you drink something that's going to kill you when you could drink
something that's going to make you more healthy and it tastes better and it
makes you feel better.
Do you have any answer to that?
I don't have.
That's right.
Cause I'm right and you're,
you're attitude is wrong.
And
uh,
books,
if you're on Amazon anyways,
where the warrior kid and Mark's mission and dismayed equals freedom field
manual,
if you want that on audio,
it's not an audible book.
It's
okay.
MP3,
iTunes,
Google play,
all that other stuff.
Extreme ownership,
which was written by me and my brother Leif Babin.
It's about leadership and we have a follow on book to that called the dichotomy
of leadership,
which is coming out September 25th and we're getting some feedback on it right
now and people are really stoked.
Lafe and I are definitely stoked on it.
It's a cool,
cool,
cool book to write.
It's a little problem,
little area that if the area that people have the most problems with.
Yeah.
How do you balance between being too much of a micromanager and being too loose?
How do you,
how do you manage the being,
communicating too much with the group and two little with how do you deal,
how do you manage being too close to you?
People are too or too distant from your people,
so all those little things,
all those little balances that you have to figure out as a leader there in that
book,
check it out.
You can preorder it anywhere if you preorder it.
It's helpful because that way our publisher who is,
you know,
just not aware,
they're not in the game.
They're not listening to actually,
some of them I listen,
it's fine.
If they're listening as podcasts,
they should be thinking not,
you know what?
We need to print a bunch of these books.
Don't miss out on the first dish.
You don't want the second a dish.
We might end up with it if you don't order it.
But,
and speaking of which,
for leadership training,
if you've read the book,
you need a little bit more inside your organization.
Echelon Front.
We solve problems through leadership.
To me,
Leif Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke,
Flint Cochran,
and now as you have heard,
my brother Mike Cirelli roster zero zero six mustard zero zero six in San
Francisco,
October 17th and 18th
Mike,
you kind of talked about this,
but you're feeling like the monster had will have good impact on people.
It most definitely is going to have impact on people.
It's been shown in just the two days I attended.
I walked away.
I came right back to Jordan and I'm like,
I call it.
I'm like,
dude,
she's like,
don't call me dude.
I'm blown away.
In fact,
the funny thing is you remember there was a green moray that came and you know
for the listeners,
hey,
you know there's,
there's strife in our rivalry,
rivalry between the communities,
all,
all for fun.
But even he looked at me and he's like,
dude,
this is amazing.
These guys are having an impact and we are going to a very unique place.
Silicon valley that is without a doubt one of the most innovative places,
sometimes lacks leadership,
has innovative products but lacks leadership.
So this is going to be magical.
Well it had to go.
Yup.
Well that's one of the things,
one of the reasons is cause they'll,
companies we work with up in Silicon Valley,
a lot of times they have the technical capacity,
they're smart,
that they even have the business understanding.
But the only thing that they need,
especially once they start to grow as they need,
they need better leadership.
And so that's why we are the companies we work up with that we work with up
there.
We know that they need this.
And so that's why we're doing this one in San Francisco,
October 17th and 18th.
Um,
come on out.
You can register it.
Extreme ownership.com.
You'll see that on this one.
You'll see like a lot of people from the last one cause they're like,
keep coming.
You know what I mean?
Because not only the updates or whatever,
but just like how you were saying earlier where the more you learn something and
then you go to the field,
you know,
you practice,
you don't practice,
you perform.
Then you're like,
oh wait,
okay.
Now other problems arise.
You understand a problem that was on the problem.
Yeah,
because I see it differently now.
I see more festival,
boom.
I'm going back to the muster,
see what I'm saying?
And then boom,
back to the field.
So you'll see people there every time updated.
And I'm going to tell you this.
So out of a sewer zero five there's this police officer came up to me,
or I should say Mountie from Nova Scotia.
Second,
do I want you,
I want you to come talk to my department.
And then,
yeah,
when he saw that I spoke with the Louisville,
Kentucky,
uh,
which are my boys police department,
the police department,
he was like,
hey,
you need to come out.
So we're coordinating,
I get to go out to Nova Scotia is a zero zero five and that's all awesome.
A,
you know,
speaking of law enforcement is because of the cause of the popularity of the
muster.
And because there's usually law enforcement,
military border patrol,
firefighters,
paramedics,
all first responders,
basically people in uniform,
they've,
they've been coming to all the monsters,
but we wanted to do one that's a little bit cheaper focused on those types of
jobs.
So we're doing something in Dallas,
Texas,
September 21st it's called the roll call.
If you want it,
it's the same register,
register extreme ownership.com.
You gotta be one of those,
you've got to be one of those jobs to come to that.
But that's going to be focused on that sort of dynamic leadership that you get
into in those situations.
So that's the role call zero zero one September 21st of course.
Now one more thing to talk about echelon front,
Overwatch,
f Overwatch.
So check it out.
Real simple to put this out.
If you're a veteran and you're either in the military and you're getting ready
to transition out of the military,
soft,
soft support,
um,
combat pilots,
if you're in that situation,
go to f overwatch.com or if you're a business that wants to bring this type of
leadership into your team,
then go to f Overwatch and you see there's real simple instruction to follow and
we'll proceed to move down the path of putting the best people in the best
positions.
And on top of that,
if you want to hang out with us a little bit more virtually until we see you in
San Francisco at the monster or until we see you at the roll call or until we
see you at the immersion camp in Maine,
then we're on the interwebs fully on the Inter webs on Twitter,
Instagram,
and Dash our phase that bulky Mike is m.
J.
Cirelli.
It's m j.
That's him on Twitter.
He's Mike Cirelli on Instagram.
And he's Michael Sorelli on Dasher
faze,
a bulky and of course echo is at Echo Charleston and I am at Jockowillink Echo.
Anything else?
Yeah,
here we go.
Going back,
you did mention,
you said Mini Bud's.
Did you say mini buds?
That's what you went through many bud.
So I think it's called something else now.
I can't recall.
So basically there is a vast pool of kids in college and at the Naval Academy
that one trout be officers in the seal teams.
Yes.
Because the competition is so fierce the summer before they graduate and
actually become commissioned as officers in the navy,
they actually have to compete for the few billets that exist for buds officers.
Okay.
And so you've got,
I think he ain't worth from a hundred,
200,
uh,
actually probably more than that trying to get into many bugs and there's only
so many,
I think like there's 30 per class.
They run too many buds every summer of about 30,
uh,
candidates each.
So 60 total and there's probably like 500 kids competing for those slots.
And then amongst those 60,
they're only going to select,
I think like 50% 30,
uh,
that actually can step into buds as navy ensigns and try to become a navy seal
officers.
So,
you know,
it goes back to that talent.
Everyone is always in a war for town looking for the best candidates.
So you go to a mini buds,
you pass,
then you go to buds.
Yup.
Yeah.
If you're lucky,
if they select you got you perform well at many buds.
And again,
this is just for your office or pipeline.
If you're enlisted guy,
you enlist in the navy and you,
you go to buds,
there's no many bud's for you.
God.
They do have a prep course now up in uh,
Chicago,
uh,
after boot camp.
You,
you stay in,
you try and they try and get you ready for buds,
but different,
obviously it's different.
I don't think that's even a selection.
It's not a selection as,
yeah,
I'm sure they could de-select you,
but the purpose isn't deselection.
No,
I think the purpose was to,
to,
to see if we get statistically increase the number of people that they get
through.
But people actually,
I think it's,
it hasn't proven effective at the end of the day.
It's,
yeah,
it's one thing for whatever reason,
it's an 80% attrition rate,
like almost all the time or 70 to 80%.
So one of my friends said this about butts,
about passing,
but this is a fact.
It's not that the telltale,
but this is the factor where if you're in a group that,
and this is going to go back to leadership.
I kind of interestingly,
if you're in a group where people are real negative and then you know,
when you,
you're negative,
you want to blame other people.
All right?
This,
if you're a negative person,
whenever you don't want to take action.
So if,
if a guy has seemingly getting ganged up on,
you know,
like if everyone's like,
hey,
you're not pulling your wig,
you know,
everyone's getting frustrated and then they,
everyone's like harping on one guy that makes them quit way quicker.
Then if everyone's like,
yeah,
it's okay.
It's okay,
we can do this.
You know how like he,
like if you have a leader who's like,
hey,
it's all good guys.
Come on.
When we got this,
we got this kind of cheering everybody on and saying like,
Hey,
we're all,
we're all a team here kind of thing.
But if you're like,
hey,
you're holding us back and everyone's ganging up on that guy,
he'll quit way quicker.
That's what he was saying.
Check there.
There's only one exception.
I think that's probably accurate for the most part.
There's only one person that I think that I've seen,
uh,
sort of defy that.
And how was Ryan Joe?
He would not get in that guy's head,
man.
And uh,
yeah.
Tough as nails.
Yeah.
Seems like that would be a factor.
But yeah,
you get bread.
There's just guys like that who were like,
no,
I'm,
I'll die before I quit.
You know,
where it's just simply not an option no matter how deep you go.
It's crazy.
But yeah,
it's going to quit.
Maybe they'll ask me what to do,
how to get through buds.
Don't quit.
That's it.
It's crazy.
Mark,
any closing thoughts?
No.
Well,
yeah.
Phew.
Just people with bank one yo to you and all the boys that I served with across
all the commands that served named mandate,
it was,
it is a brotherhood a while,
might not have gotten along with all of you.
Definitely learn something from everyone.
And A,
it is a brotherhood that you will never replace them.
And,
and that was an honor to serve alongside those guys.
And then,
um,
I think the last two was one of my kids.
Uh,
Cameron then,
and Caden,
I mean,
that is any man's legacy is how you raise your kids and they mean the world to,
to,
to me.
And then,
uh,
the last person he's changed my life is a,
my fiance,
which I hope you guys are reserved from the date.
Uh,
Jordan,
um,
who's changed my perspective on a lot of things and you know,
helped me through a,
uh,
what is not easy for any veteran.
And that is that that is transitioning out of the military.
And,
uh,
I'll tell you what are positivity is infectious.
And she calls me out on my,
you know what,
all the damn time,
she's younger than me and a,
it's a hit to the ego.
So thanks to uh,
to,
to that entire group and a bubby gas.
Awesome man.
Well,
like I said,
of course,
thanks for coming on.
And also like I already said,
and which I can never say enough.
Thanks for your service in the defense of our freedom.
You're talking about all of those deployments over and over and over again,
man.
Keep going back into the fray.
It's freaking awesome and thank you for doing it.
And congrats on your retirement.
I don't know if I ever even said that to you and you're retired,
but it's,
uh,
I'm glad that you got to be able to retire and it's awesome to be freaking
working with you again.
So thanks Mike.
I'm looking forward to many more years.
Thanks brother.
And everyone else in the military that's still out there holding the line,
doing those deployments over and over again.
Thank you.
And to the police and law enforcement and firefighters and paramedics and border
patrol and the rest of you that are holding the line here at home.
Thanks for what you're doing and to your families as well.
Thank you for supporting those that support us and to the rest of you.
I know life isn't perfect and I know life can be hard,
but it is still life
and it's your life.
And there are those that have given their lives so that we can have ours.
So
for them,
for those heroes,
live a good life,
live the best life you can by going out there every single day
and getting after it.
And until next time,
this is Mike,
an echo and Jocko out.